welcome folks for the uh
crossover first crossover meeting uh the
uh
this is
Wednesday the
wealth
and why don't we start off with the
pledges of Allegiance
foreign
the first last thing on the docket uh is
Senate bill
entitled relative to payments for
restoration of certain jurisdictional
resource losses
and
Senator Waters the Florida Georgia thank
you very much uh good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee uh
Senator David Waters District 4 bringing
before your Senate Bill 56 relative
payment for Upland resource uh losses
and um this bill uh really with the
Department of Environmental Services
meant to expand the options for
developers so they can get their
projects done particularly in the
coastal zone and so what it does is it
expands the kinds of projects that would
be eligible for payment into the
compensatory fund rather than having to
find other lands to do mitigation
projects on so we think this is a kind
of a good solution to making sure the
projects can get done it does apply
particularly to the coastal zone which
is very particularly managed under
federal statute in the coastal zone
program
um and uh so I just I want to emphasize
with us that there's no new regulation
here uh if rather providing additional
option for
um developers so uh if you look to the
bill you'll see how we do that
um it adds a line seven and eight to the
existing statute restoration or
enhancement of any jurisdictional area
identified under RSA
42 a30b well one might ask what is that
well we have a new paragraph down below
um new section uh 482 a30 B and this is
where it allows for the payment for
other jurisdictional resource losses and
no particularly uh the application to
the coastal zone for losses to sand
dunes undeveloped portions of duly
established 100 foot buffers of
designated Prime wetlands an undeveloped
title buffer zones in lieu of payment
and then the sums in accordance with the
sums as they already done elsewhere this
will help us in terms of coastal
development and providing some more
options it also helps us in regards with
use of federal funds as well on the
coastal
coastal zone so this would be a very
effective tool for developers and we
thought it made a lot of sense to do
is there any questions for the senator
or should we wait for uh
Darlene uh divorced you'll be able to
listen
bring us up the speed of Representative
Vale
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
Senator Waters
I'm looking at um
actually the section right after the new
section where it says 482 a30b on line
16 of page
I think one
um it just says here for losses to sand
dunes undeveloped portions of duly
established 100 foot buffers which you
just read of dust designated Prime
Wetlands could you tell me what more
about the prime Wetlands that we're
talking about yes these are as defined
you know as as Des defines Prime
Wetlands because their their
contribution to Wetland to water
resources and their sensitivity of their
areas this is language is actually
cotton cognate to what already exists in
the
um in a here and so you can look up that
definition I don't know if we have
somebody here from Des to talk more
about that but this is the kind of the
the dunes the Upland the resources and
the prime wetlands are what's covered
here and uh I will note that um you know
Prime wetlands are obviously something
of great great concern because of
regulations around it all around the
State and Gary Abbott of the general
contractors came in and just wanted to
make sure that we weren't talking
Statewide here this is just for that
that very particular environment in the
coastal zone and was not going to
further regulate just provide further
options for compensation instead of
mitigation so that satisfies the
contractors and that's
that's where we got to the Comfort level
and what we were talking about with
these uh aspects of the um
of the ecology there
representative thank you and thank you
for taking my question does this mean
that a developer can pay money
to
to use a wetland
by his way is way out of maintaining a
wetlander so they don't have to replace
a wetland they now can just pay money
and the Wetland goes away and we have
sixty five thousand dollars for an acre
thanks for your question you got it
um that if it's not possible do a
mitigation project which is often the
option for alteration of um of these
areas you could pay into the
compensatory fund and then be able to do
your project
and
or for a follow-up
and this is something that Des supports
yeah they actually brought this I don't
think it's officially listed as a
requested apartment but they brought
this forward to me
has been it being something that would
help out
um this this kind of development
it
used to be
specific this is not about that uh that
mitigation law that's been in effect for
quite a few years uh this is just a an
addition to the mitigation law for those
for these specific
areas
that there's a question as to whether
because of their specific specificity in
the way they are they uh it's mitigation
is uh something that probably is going
to going to be used because of the
Rarity of their uh it's tough to go make
sand dunes I think yeah thank you Mr
chairman I mean that's exactly it that
it just there are some areas where you
just there's not an available mitigation
project that makes sense so that the
payment into the fund is a good option
so that you don't then stall out just
because it's not possible to do a
mitigation project and the project can
go forward but that fund will be there
to help do mitigation work elsewhere
thank you anyone else
representative
LaMontagne and then representative thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um but
in regards to the question
representative wolf raised and
if the medication can't occur it is
saying you can pay into the fund and
develop anyway and isn't that a net loss
to our Wetlands protection
well thanks for your question and um I
you know I think that what what we know
with Des is how carefully they balance
out
um the ways in which it does make sense
to enable a project to go forward or
whether something just can't happen
and so I think it's always a process of
negotiation and and review and this
seems in an appropriate way to um to be
able to have this tool in the toolbox so
that a good result can occur that would
protect the environment but also allow
um development to occur where it makes
sense for it to occur
I think you'll be able to get some
examples from the Des if they're if
they're here today yes they're someone
is here and I think well as we go on
discussing it like I think there will be
some discussion I think because
obviously there's questions of
the people new to the committee as to
the mitigation fund and those of us
have have seen it in operation and it
actually uh it it increases our ability
to uh to uh to get Pro to get good
quality Wetlands because if the way your
your the amount of money that is
collected you can then buy get a better
property
to and more have a better effect uh in
in another area
all right correct uh anyone else
or previously representative sorry thank
you senator for taking my question a
follow-up to representative Lamontagne
I don't see maybe I'm reading this
proposal incorrectly but I don't see
that it says if mitigation is not
possible then you can pay to get out
I I think the representatives concern
and my concern is um just to be clear
this almost as an option for the
developer even if mitigation is
available he can buy out I just want to
get it clear is that correct thanks
thanks for your question
um I think that you know this is
obviously focused on creating this new
section of a30b but um a30 A and B are
in that in in 40 to a
um you'll see all the
um laying out of Statute around
mitigation and protection of these areas
and uh so that that is what is Opera
operable this area this part of the
statute gets into those things where
um you know it it it's not you know one
of the we want to protect the
environment I think that's the bottom
line and mitigation is a good thing but
sometimes mitigation doesn't make a
whole lot of sense in a given area just
because there might not be enough
resources available or just the nature
of the landscape and this then says okay
make your payment
into that fund that fund and can be used
in projects the Des thinks actually get
more bang for the buck than trying to do
some mitigation would in an area and I
do hope that Des will be able to explain
some of the projects under the way on
the Dune restoration other things that
are being funded down along the Seacoast
have done a lot of a lot of good
um and more than just one project at a
time might have done in one particular
area
appreciate your answer but I don't know
if it answered my question is the option
to the developer not the Des so I
represent some developers so they might
look at it and say yeah I can mitigate
but it's going to take me longer so I'm
just going to pay the 65 000 and get out
of it and then I don't have to mitigate
even if mitigation is available I'm not
against the proposal I just trying to
make it clear I I hear you and I think
Des is going to do a better job of
getting into the
if not the weeds the eelgrass on that
any more questions
being none thank you very much thank you
always
Darlene forced representing New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services
good morning folks thank you for having
me my name is Darlene Forrest I am the
administrator of the Department of
Environmental Services Wetlands Bureau I
feel like I should apologize to Senator
waters for not telling him in advance
that I would be backing him up
as a
as a individual testifying on this bill
rather than read the letter of testimony
that we submitted as a department I will
probably just answer some of the
questions and explain a little bit about
what the Aquatic resource mitigation
fund is how it functions and what it
means to
Wetlands protection in the state of New
Hampshire
so yes the Department of Environmental
Services does support this bill and this
legislation
Senator Waters comments regarding the
fact that this does not expand
jurisdiction is correct our current
jurisdiction includes our aquatic
resources our Wetlands but it also
includes some Upland areas there is a
100 foot tidal buffer zone
that is established in the law
there is a provision in the law that
allows municipalities to identify
certain Wetlands complexes within their
boundaries
and to vote on them locally and
designate them as Prime submit the
boundaries of those Wetlands to us and
we will give them special protection or
at least apply a stricter standard for
development to those Wetlands that the
town has voted to designate as Prime
there are only a handful of talents that
have done this between 2011 and 2013
there was a provision in the law that
allowed those towns to also adopt a 100
foot buffer around those Wetlands that
is no longer an option but for those
towns who did it within that time frame
they do retain that buffer and we do
also recognize that thus you see the
language a duly authorized or adopted
100 foot buffer around certain Prime
wetlands
I believe there are eight towns in the
state of New Hampshire that took
advantage of that many of them are in
the Southeast corner of the state
uh sand dunes again
there's only a few of them all Coastal
resources obviously
they are jurisdictional they are very
strictly regulated in accordance with
the language of the law
there are times when there are projects
that cannot avoid impacting those
resources
questions were asked about can you
simply pay to impact a wetland and the
answer is no
Wetlands by rule by Statute in some
cases in accordance also with Army Corps
regulations who back us up on the
federal level on navigable Waters and
Waters of the U.S and EPA regulations do
not allow us to Simply accept money
and
therefore you have paid and you have
bought this Wetland and you may impact
it
the standards are minimization and
avoidance if you can avoid the Wetland
by regulations you are supposed to avoid
the wetlands if you can't avoid the
wetlands then you should minimize your
impacts to those wetlands and if your
project is such
that you cannot avoid or minimize then
at a certain threshold you are required
to mitigate for those wetlands
New Hampshire's current threshold for
mitigation on square footage of wetlands
is 10 000 square feet
Federal threshold is five thousand
square feet so we are not as strict as
the federal government at this time
in those cases where you have to
mitigate the question becomes how do you
mitigate
in the past when this program when the
mitigation requirements first came into
play in the late mid to late 90s the
idea was that you would mitigate on site
or you would mitigate within the
immediate vicinity but that puts the
pressure on the contractor to identify a
project that may or may not be on land
that they own odds are it's not
find something within the town
coordinate with the other landowner and
then
do a restoration project that will be
successful Wetlands restoration is not
easy it is not something that the
average contractor does know how to do
what this program allows is for a
contractor who has a developer who has a
project that requires mitigation if they
can find a locally available
what we would call permittee responsible
mitigation project that they can
complete and are willing to complete
they will always have that option but
more often that is just not something
that they are Adept at that they are
qualified to do
or that they can find locally this Pro
this program the wetlands aquatic
resource impacts have been allowed to
pay into this program
for close to 20 years now
we did not realize until very recently
that this did not extend to our adjacent
Upland jurisdictional areas this will
extend this option to those adjacent
Upland resource areas tool a further
allow contractors to Avail themselves of
this program what it does allow is that
money is paid into a grant program we
just issued 17 grants this past fall and
we are opening the next Grant round
applications are due in May
and we are looking at projects with this
with these funds they go to agencies
like trout unlimited local
municipalities local conservation
programs non-profit conservation
programs they go to programs such as
restoring and developing living
shorelines on the Seacoast region
Dam removals
land protection around Water Resources
such as Town Water Supplies
they go to a various a variety of
environmental enhancement and
restoration projects and what it does is
it creates a pool of money money funds
we we monitor where funds are collected
from and where the projects are occur
funds have to be spent in the Watershed
where the impacts that resulted in their
payment occurred
so they are based on service area they
are tied back to their original
Watershed with the impacts
and the idea is this pool of money is
available to
people who are environmentally vested
who know in their communities where
there is a need for restoration or
enhancement or an opportunity for
restoration and enhancement and it
allows towns to apply for a board
project
proponents to apply for a larger pool of
funds than they would ever have had
before
so does it provide an opportunity for a
developer to do the project more quickly
and not have to do the mitigation
themselves
yes does it also provide for
environmental professionals on the other
side of this this development spectrum
and protection protection Spectrum to
to complete projects that have
significant environmental value in the
same Watershed and Community General
area of the communities yes it does so
by doing this we believe in the EPA we
do this in coordination with the EPA and
Army Corps and we are considered one of
the top nationally recognized
environmental programs in the country
this program is nationally recognized as
a good solution
so we believe you get the best of both
worlds you have
efficient development environmental
permitting where it's appropriate
because you've still met that
minimization and avoidance standard but
you also have a much more efficient and
productive with a higher level of
success opportunity for environmental
restoration and protection on the other
side so we are the facilitators between
the development side of the spectrum and
the protection and restoration side of
the protection we we do just that we are
the mediators and the flow that gets
both parties where they hope to be or at
least that is our goal
does anyone that's does anyone have any
questions based on that
representative
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
Bill indulge me for a minute because I'm
newer to the committee but I'm not new
to the wetlands mitigation thing
um
so I think thank you very much for
explaining to me what's happened in
Wetlands mitigation over the last
20 years or so it sounds like I've
noticed a decrease in on-site Wetlands
mitigation and construction projects
things like the circumferential Highway
that never happened where part of it was
built in the Hudson Nashua area and they
did a very nice Wetlands mitigation
project in the near the Sagamore Bridge
and and Hudson and it was beautiful I
see the birds and things there all the
time when I drive over that bridge
but now I understand better why there
are fewer
Wetlands mitigation projects on site
never knew this was happening but you're
saying it's been quite successful where
developers pay into a fund and things
happen in the area or elsewhere
so my question is a couple couple of
questions that feel indulge me the first
is
how are how is it monitored to make sure
the funds are spent on site or in the
area and can you define in the area and
during what period of time do those
funds need to be fed do you spend be
spent in that
area so I believe we are required to
spend those funds within three years
the monitoring is completed we must
report to the Army Corps and the EPA
epa's goal for Wetlands protection is no
net loss of functions and values
so we do complete an annual report if
you would like I can make sure that that
annual report to the Federal Government
is made available to this committee for
your review I believe it's also posted
on our website so it's done yeah so
it is the
the EPA and Army Corps calculate the
amount of acreage and square footage
lost
then they look at what we're issuing for
Grants
they will then they they do it as a kind
of a credit and debit we would most
normal people would call it a credit and
debit program for what is lost versus
what is created they weirdly call it
credit and credit I will warn you now
that when you get the report that's
rather confusing sure but they will
monitor the grants determine if the
project was successful
and then based on the success of the
project let us know if we received
adequate credits to offset losses
so we have a responsibility to work with
those folks who receive Grant Awards to
make sure those projects are successful
and they are assessed based on
both the functions and values that were
lost in projects as and the types of
resources that were impacted versus the
functions and values that were gained
and I will also tell you that because of
New Hampshire's topography and just the
way
um
our communities are situated it is very
difficult to do large-scale
mitigation projects unlike some
opportunities and in other states that
have had larger Wetlands complexes
so there has been a focus on
preservation buffering
a lot of aquatic resource passage so
bridge and Culvert improvements to
to reduce flooding improve our fisheries
and aquatic organisms those have been
very popular projects
we are starting to see more Dam removals
that said the focus moving forward that
we have with our federal Partners is
they want to see more restoration
so in this grant round that we are
opening for this coming season we are
focused on restoration projects so I
suspect you will see more of that if you
had noticed a reduction of it in the
past
great follow-up
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking a couple more
um I remember and and maybe it's just my
uh getting older but I seem to remember
some requirement for Mitigation Of like
a ten to one mitigation is that a crazy
memory nope still exists so it does
still exist so you take an acre of
wetlands you have to replace or create
10 acres of wetlands if we lose one
credit we are responsible for recovering
10. okay
as senile as I thought I was so so it's
really ten ten ten to one and and that's
directly measured it is tied to resource
type it can be as high as ten to one for
certain resource types such as emergent
Wetlands marshes scrub shrub Wetlands
there are other types of wetlands the
adjacent Uplands
they are a lower ratio the adjacent
Uplands are not at a 10 to 1 ratio there
is a table within the chapter 800 of the
wetlands rules
that is available to both individuals
who are applying for Grants and those
who are looking to provide mitigation
for what the ratio would be for the
given resource type that they are
impacting and I'm not sure I heard a
follow-up
I'm not sure I heard the percentage
though so does a developer essentially
what I'm asking is does anybody bother
to do on-site mitigation anymore isn't
it just easier to factor it into the
cost of the project and the cost of
doing business just pay the fine and let
somebody else worry about it
there are times when on-site mitigation
will be required I know but one percent
of the time because if I'm a developer I
would just Factor it into the cost and
say let it be some some other expert's
problem because frankly like you said
there's a lot of other people who are
better at doing it and it's more
effective elsewhere
it is
if you are dealing with a prime wetland
because of the language of prime Wetland
law what we have in in our section of
the Prime Wetland law
that will need to be on site because it
says that's project on site shall have
no significant net loss on site that
forces you to do it there
so in those types of projects we're
going to see a hundred percent but you
are correct in other types of projects
it is very difficult
to provide that compensation on site
and and in honesty the other reason is
that not only is it very difficult and
unlikely to find a developer who does it
but our ratio for Success on a
three-year monitoring a three-year
monitoring of that mitigation was not
providing results that gave us
confidence it gets you have a
development completed they've attempted
on-site mitigation and it's a small
project and our success rate long term
and seeing environmental benefit
was not backing up it favored having
professionals do it off-site
so it's a very low percentage last one
I promise
so they get a thumbs down on the
three-year monitoring and then what
happens they have to do it over
we would have rules in place to say you
have to redo the plantings
what we're finding is frequently on a
small project you are chasing hydrology
you're chasing soil conditions and this
the size of it is not getting your
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so I
um I'm trying to understand if
um you know the what this bill is
covering is things like sand dunes and
um
and uh title buffer zones right we have
a very small Coastline right
um I don't see in the language where it
says if you affect sand dunes you have
to and you pay into the fund that you
repair of sand dunes how is that fact
so this admittedly you've chosen the
Sand Dune example and this is very
unique
um we have only ever had three
applications and this goes to the can I
just buy it we have only ever had three
applications to impact sand dunes before
and we had denied them all the project
in question here
is
a bridge in a highway which has no other
place to go and this will allow us
rather than having dot who is not really
in the Sand Dune business
try to attempt to recreate sand dunes to
allow us to work with environmental
professionals
because of the resource type impacted we
are looking at we are already working
with others to identify potential
restoration sites to make this work we
are focused on attempting to use this to
restore enhance or create additional
sand dunaries that is part of our credit
measurement that is part of our if you
lose a particular function or loss in a
watershed you attempt to provide a
function or loss function or value and a
watershed you attempt to provide that
function and value in this case sand
dunes are highly unique there's no other
place we could put them that loss has to
go we have to attempt to
ReStore in the Sea Coast region
thank you Mr chair um just one quick
follow-up that that was excellent thank
you I
um you said that you have not approved
three cases can you explain the criteria
for when you know an environmental
impact in Wetlands would not be approved
so under the statute
our first is
um
if it's avoidable you must if you can if
you can possibly avoid an impact
you need to avoid an impact
unfortunately in the case of crossing
over a water body at some point you're
going to impact the banks and resources
on either side of that water body
so
we do not permit expansion of any other
like if you simply have a residential
development and with the laws that have
been in place for 30 40 years the the
expectation that buying a sand dune
would be a reasonable expectation of
residential development in the sand dune
it isn't there if you have areas one
would hope that are not sand dune you
would need to build in the areas that
are not sand dune first
we will simply not approve that kind of
an impact given the number of species uh
the coastal protection functionality of
them their fragility
so
you have that first thing is
minimization and avoidance so then the
question becomes well
is I can't minimize or avoid I need to
do this and therefore I can't complete
my project without doing it the standard
then becomes and it is not a simple
standard to meet for us
we would have to show that the
needs and expectations of the landowner
are outweighed by the general interests
of the people of New Hampshire
so we would actually have to tie it into
our environmental purpose of Commerce
navigation wildlife
species of significant value or
importance
Shoreline stability Coastal stability
and we would most likely tie it into
both wildlife of importance species of
importance and Shoreline stabilities
because
the what some people may not realize
because we don't have that much
coastline is that the sand dunes are in
fact important to our Coastal stability
it is in our storm events one of those
things that absorbs the power of the sea
before it gets to other more sensitive
areas like us
so we would be looking at showing why
the individual Property Owners interest
was outweighed by Public Safety
as well as
endangered or threatened species or
um
thank you Mr chair
my question is just is this bill ready
to go the way it is amended by the
Senate right now
okay thank you so much
representative Ryan
um I'm just trying to organize this in
my head right so I'm going to build
something
um at first I need to avoid any valuable
area then if I can't avoid I have to
mitigate I can't find a decent
mitigation project or a valuable
mitigation project or I don't know how
to do that then I pay and someone else
creates that for me does this result for
New Hampshire in more quality and
valuable
mitigation projects
we believe that this methodology
provides a better quality mitigation and
a better overall environmental outcome
than if we were to attempt to have every
applicant do permittee responsible
anyone else see representative Rock
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I just want to
follow up um on something you said
earlier so the mitigation projects that
are receive grants from this fund
do they have to be projects within the
Watershed of where the impacted project
was funds must be spent within the
Watershed for which they were collected
seeing no more questions
nope
I thought you said you owe ahead to the
last one I did but then but then
representative Vale brought something to
mind
um
so thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking additional question
um I'm operating under the assumption
that uh
the fiscal note is correct in the
analysis is correct it does say paying
in lieu of fee would be optional
and it says that the department States
because this bill only creates the
option
to pay and Lou into the arm fund uh no
way to calculate number of applicants
choose this new Option so is it as it
currently is amended you said it's ready
I'm a little confused about that don't
we want it to not be an option shouldn't
we tighten this up a bit before it's
ready to go we and would you support
that
I don't think we would support that no
sir because if if in fact you have a
unique situation where there is a
project locally that would mitigate for
we would not want to
tell the contractor that the developer
that they could not do it or work with
if a municipality was Forward Thinking
and the municipality said we have
projects locally that could be done and
they're shovel ready
we would not want to strip them of that
option if it's available and it can be
done
they'll still be the monitoring they'll
they'll still need to show that it's
successful it will still need to offset
the functions and values of the impacts
there may be cases and there are not it
is not unheard of that there are cases
where you have a certain amount of
permittee responsible and a small amount
paid into the Aquatic resource
mitigation fund but we do not want to
strip that option no agreed we want them
to do that
the mitigation outside if possible
when I'm
is there anyone else
seeing no one
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Kevin Nyon and I manage the
environmental office at the Department
of Transportation and the the dot is uh
in favor in support of this bill
um for a number of reasons you've heard
of a lot of good information from the
senator and from Ms forced but this does
provide us with um with another with
that option right so as the dot
right now we if there are on-site
mitigation opportunities uh like like Ms
Force said we do look at look for those
opportunities uh as a as a first choice
it is not our preference our preference
is to make a payment into the Aquatic
resources mitigation fund as mitigation
so as a as a as a developer we feel that
those funds are better placed or those
those projects are better placed in the
hands of those that do that more
frequently so the environment mental
contractors so to speak doing those
environmental projects
we also find that that when though when
we do make those payments for our
resource losses that
um the I would say the the long-term
monitoring is in the hands of somebody
else the responsibility should something
fail is in is the responsibility of
somebody else so it really puts our our
money goes uh in a in a better place
because others who are better suited to
do that work are doing that work the
other benefit is that as a D.O.T we have
a number of well larger and smaller
projects and those smaller projects
oftentimes require mitigation that could
be worth say something on the order of
twenty thousand dollars per project to
come up with a project that's twenty
thousand dollars that's going to have an
environmental benefit is is is uh is
difficult
um because twenty thousand dollars
doesn't go very far so to speak but when
that money is pooled with other are
resources at Department of Environmental
services within that Watershed they're
able to come up with bigger better more
you know more well thought out projects
so it really does put that that in the
hands of the right people but we also
like the option so as the representative
asked that there there are options
on-site mitigation well first of all
obviously avoidance minimization and
then the on-site mitigation and then the
the payment our preference I will say is
a payment and it certainly does bear out
in our project so for example uh the the
example of the sand dune
um our Hampton Bay Bridge Project
Seabrook Hampton which we're working on
right now scheduled we're working
through the product development process
all along because the arm fund has been
available for decades all along through
the development we were planning on
making that arm fund payment our our on
the order of three hundred twenty
thousand dollars and I will provide you
a letter uh as well that that's that
identifies that
um but because we've been moving along
in that direction because it was as Miss
Force said it was only relatively
recently where we learned that these
certain Upland resources weren't
available for the armed fund that we
were caught mid-stream
um having to look for a permittee
responsible mitigation project and as
misfort said with with with
um
um sand dunes it's extremely difficult
so uh so that's part of one of the
biggest reasons we're supporting this
bill obviously as well is because
um it does allow us to have more
efficient and streamlined
um
Transportation projects without this
bill now that project does run the risk
of being delayed because as an agency if
we are if we don't have the option of
making that arm fund payment we're going
to have to continue to look for
opportunities to do that other
mitigation and we're not able to get a
permit until we have that secured so
without this legislation it does have
the possibility of delaying not only
that project but another Seacoast
project so I guess to summarize our
support puts the money in the right
hands it allows for bigger better
projects
it allows for a more streamlined project
development and I would say over the
last
15 years as an agency we've availed
ourselves to the tune of
13 to 15 million dollars towards the
this program so it's one that we do
support so um I'm happy to take any
questions that you might have
any questions by anyone from the
committee
seeing uh oh Senator Darby thank you
um Mr chair thanks for taking my
question just you mentioned a couple of
Seacoast projects um
there must be a is there a process that
um it goes through that you go through
as part of evaluating
um that process in terms of the impacts
to the you know to the wetlands and
things that basically justifies that
project
um regardless of this payment just the
the fact that it that it's the you know
the right project to benefit Society
versus the Wetland costs
sure thank you for the question most of
our projects are federally funded
and even the ones that aren't we have uh
so the the federal projects we have to
follow the National Environmental Policy
Act which does prescribe that avoidance
minimization mitigation model
So to that end we're required to for
every project that we undertake we look
at the existing resources we look at all
we look at what we're proposing to do
alternatives to that proposal and then
we are look and then we are kind of
bound to select the project that meets
the purpose and need in this case for
bridge projects it's safe efficient
Transportation network over those
resources but that also meets that
purpose and need but also minimizes
environmental impact so to the extent
that we are impacting tidal buffer zones
for those projects or I'm sorry title
buffer zone and Sand Dune for that
project it's because that has already
been determined to be the least
environmentally damaging practicable
alternative that meets the purpose and
the need for the project so it's almost
those impacts uh in in the in the
verbiage of of Des are unavoidable
seeing no other questions
thank you very much and
last speaker
Mr Abbott from the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire
the guy who pays
foreign
thank you chairman for the record Gary
Abbott the Executive Vice President of
the associated general contractors of
New Hampshire it's always great to come
before this committee with everybody
talking in support of the legislation
including me we support this version
that was amended in the Senate that is
before you and I say that because I had
concerns when we went to the Senate I
was very lucky to work with Kevin Nyan
and Darlene Forrest of the two agencies
to work out the language for
clarification we're looking at this as
more of a language clarification of what
is jurisdictional under the Department
of Environmental Services and I state
that because
um I I want to tell you this as well
I represent commercial contractors as
well as consultants who do the in
Engineers that do this design work for
permits we get a lot of permits Wetlands
is one of them we get Town permits we
get everything there's a lot of permits
that a development has to get but when
it comes to Wetlands I can tell you this
the developer wants to avoid them 100
because then we don't have to get a
Wetlands permit so if they can do
anything to make sure that they don't
touch a wet lens or go buy these
jurisdictional areas they're going to do
that
the second thing they're going to do is
in the old days they're probably a lot
bigger sites that they were able to
mitigate there are less of those today
that you see development on so you end
up the developer hires one of these
Consultants that belong to our
association that go out and try to find
mitigation projects they go to the towns
they go elsewhere and this they're
looking to try to solve the mitigation
now the permit process it's not totally
in the developer's hands I guess I just
want to put that they have to get
approval of the permit from the
Department the Department's going to
review it and ask you questions like you
show you can't avoid this area or
mitigate this the developer is going to
have to work with that
so they'll look at those options the
in-lu fee has worked for years regarding
a wetland this bill clarifies for
jurisdictional Uplands that are in
control of Des which we're fine with
because they've always had that control
the other part of this and I don't want
you to miss this because
I too if I'm you I'm looking at this
bill and I'm reading I think
lines 19 through 27 and I want to
highlight this because
my members are always on me
that they think they're paying way too
much into the in-lu fee because what you
read you have to really look at lines 23
and Below it's a formula it's a
calculation it's based on inflation it's
based it's not it's not the choice that
most developers want to pick because
it's costly
it's not but they might have to only
pick that one because there's nothing
else available and if it works for their
project so I want to tell you that
I have on my side this is not the least
expensive way to go this is a very
costly way and developers make that
choice but I agree with the Department
of dot that we've always believe that
the mitigation fund paying into that is
better for the environment
and the reason it's better for the
environment is that you get this
mitigation fund that costs you more
because there's a formula just as uh the
representative talked about you know ten
to one five to one there's an
inflationary number right off the bat
because of the type of wetland or
mitigation but it goes into this fund it
can do better things you can take
a number of projects bulk the money
together and do a project that might
help water quality with the town or
other bigger benefits that you wouldn't
do on site doing little mitigations here
and there so it is better for the
environment EPA agrees core of engineer
agree
this money is better done that way and
the Des I'm not so sure they completely
explained
they have a grant procedure they get
this money they have the watersheds and
then you have people apply with their
projects and they select the best ones
for mitigation in that area so it's it's
a great program in the sense if you look
at all the components
and so we're happy here today to uh
we're glad for the opportunity that
Senator Waters in The Hearing in the
Senate said Gary in the Departments can
you get together to make sure the
language works for all the parties and
I'm glad to be here today to say we are
happy with how this bill is drafted and
we think it will work
so with that I would end my testimony
and hope the committee supports this
bill
Mr
representative the cube
thank you Mr chairman
do you know what the jurisdictional
areas are that are defined under 42a
30-b yes if you want to go to line 16
through 18
um you can see it right there that is
what is the jurisdictional areas that
are under the state 16 A10 see on 16
Dunes undeveloped portions of the
Wetland 100 foot buffer zone that's
under the Jersey that's the new section
thank you that's the new section and
those are the specific items that were
jurisdictional before under the rules
this clears it up for statutory 42a 30
B is a new session you've got it added
to freshwater and tidal wetlands which
is 8 30. okay got it thank you for
all right okay anyone else
thank you very much
close the hearing on House Bill excuse
okay
I'll open the hearing and Senate Bill
sick Senate Bill 60 relative to water
quality
and Senator Gray
Laura is yours well thank you very much
my name is James Gray I represent Senate
District Six which starts up in Alton
gilmanson goes down Route 11 to
Rochester
uh
water quality okay
there's uh Rochester uh went to kachiko
River and the things that it is uh
listed as impaired for makes this an
issue that uh
they sought me out to come make some
changes
in the past we have discussed whether or
not we should do measurements based on
concentration or saturation and all
these other things
the department came to me again and said
that they believed that they had
something that would work as a
compromise not only the department but
the
advisors that we have in the city of
Rochester have all come together and
said this is a good next step and I'm
going to let them talk to the details of
it again what we're trying to do is is
to find something that is
a reasonable approach both for the
department and for the municipalities in
the state and reach that compromise so
if there's any questions chair I'd be
happy to answer them but I think right
off to my right is the person that you
really want to talk to
I would I would tend to agree uh unless
some member of the committee has a real
pressing question of the senator
I would say thank you very much
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Ted deers I am the assistant
director of The Water Division at the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and it is a great
pleasure to be with you this morning to
talk about SB 60. so I would describe
sb60 as an Omnibus water quality bill it
includes a whole bunch of things related
to water quality at the face of it it
looks a little complex I have prepared
for you both a letter of testimony as
well as a PowerPoint a set of slides
that you have in front of you that help
you to work through the various
different pieces parts of this bill I
would say that primarily This falls into
the Arcane world of water quality
regulation and how we do that in New
Hampshire so um I we had debates in
within our our department about whether
this was an Omnibus or a mini bus or or
some other kind of bus but we're going
to call this our Omnibus water quality
I think I'm going to be thrown under the
bus so
this includes really six aspects that
are and if you look at our letter of
testimony and if you look at um say page
two of the the presentation it talks
about the various different parts of
this bill
and I want to talk about the first set
of things that are included are really
related to what's called 401 section 401
Water Quality certifications so just a
really quick background on what this is
section 401 of the Clean Water Act tells
uh this is a federal federal to Clean
Water Act says that any project that
requires a federal permit
or license and has the potential the
discharge that is discharged to
a water of the United States
requires the state to certify that that
project will meet our water quality
standards
so our water quality standards are
written in envwq 1700 that is something
that's been through JL car those are
approved they're approved by EPA so they
become also Federal standards under the
Clean Water Act so our section 401
program which is a it's a certification
someone comes to us with a project
um Kevin Nyan has been the victim of
many of these kinds of of certifications
that they come to us with a project that
requires a an individual Wetlands permit
from the Army Corps of Engineers
they bring us that application they do
an application to the state we look at
that and we decide does this meet all
the water quality standards that we have
in the state we certify that then the
federal permit can move on so that's how
the program works it's not well
described currently within the statutes
so this is ostensibly kind of like a
permitting program but you will see in
the statute 45 a12 that it has none of
the trappings of a of a permitting
program that's the first set of parts of
this of this bill are to bring some
structure around that why do we want to
do that
primarily so that the applicants that
are coming in and the state that's doing
the regulating have a common
understanding of how this is going to
work
I will also say and I'm going to come
back to this a couple of times that we
are currently writing rules for our 401
certifications those I'm hoping will be
over the next year after this gets
passed we'll have some rules that will
help to even better on make an
understanding of how the applicants and
how The Regulators operate in this
program
so the first couple of these the first
one of these is allows the ability to
for the state to be able to waive a 401
certification the Clean Water Act allows
for states to do one of four things with
a water quality certification request
you can approve it you can approve it
with conditions you can waive it or you
can deny it and so right now in state
law we do not have the ability to waive
a 401 certification
why would we want to do that well a
really good example project is the water
line that they're replacing that goes
from Portsmouth to Dover underneath the
bridges there on the Great Bay
that project because it's in tidal
waters requires an individual permit
however all they're doing is picking up
picking up a pipe that's on the bottom
replacing it with another pipe same
location we've already done projects in
this area they have lots of other
permits that they are going to do they
have best management practices that
they're going to do for us to take the
time to go through a long permitting
process and something that is
essentially has no environmental impact
is a silly exercise for them and it's a
silly exercise for us that's the kind of
project that we would like to be able to
wave so that that's that's the first
provision the second provision is talks
about processing time
if because we don't have rules and
because we don't have current statutory
language for processing time we would
revert back to the underlying statutes
in the state which would require us to
make some action within 60 days
some of these permits these 401
certifications have a year-long
application period through the federal
government so that would be problematic
for both applicant and the federal
agency as well as the state if we had to
revert to that so this puts in time
frames again building an expectation by
the applicant of what they would need to
accomplish when they can expect feedback
from the state again building those
those aspects of what a proper
permitting program would look like
number three I'm going to spend just a
little time about because I have a
feeling that there's going to be other
um and I'm going to talk about also the
um the process time frames one other
aspect of that that I think Mr Nyan may
want to talk about and certainly one
that he testified in in the Senate
one of the aspects of the 401 program is
that the federal government sets a
reasonable time frame that's what they
call it they call it a reasonable time
frame for the state to have action on
the one of these certifications
when we
um when they do that we have to be able
to comply with that and so if if we set
these time frames in statute you saw the
50 days and and 120 days time for people
to be able to to be able to interact on
these kind of complex permits
that if we if the federal government
sets something shorter than that we
don't want to have a conflict between
State Statute and what the federal
requirements are so I have an amendment
that is in your letter of testimony that
would deal with that issue that
amendment has gone to uh dot to take a
look at we work through the language
with them we think that this will allow
for both us to have that reasonable
expectation by the by the by the
regulated Community as to what it would
be required and when but it also sets up
that safety valve sort of the federal
government chooses a shorter time frame
we don't have to deny a permit simply
because they didn't have enough time
so this allows us to be able to do that
I think
um that language is has again has been
vetted uh through the Departments and I
think it's going to be helpful to be
able to make it so that there's not a
the the next part of this is this goes
to
um
to section uh three
is
um section three is about when water
withdrawals need to have uh some some
certification by the state one of the
other things that 485 a12 does is it
sets up a system for water withdrawals
from surface water you're probably
familiar because it's been in this
committee a whole bunch of times the
large groundwater withdrawal program in
the state so for for if you were going
to put in a well into groundwater for
greater than 20 000 gallons a day or six
hundred thousand gallons over the course
of a month you're required to get a uh a
large groundwater withdrawal permit from
the Department you're also required to
register as a water user if you're using
the the current version of 485a this is
this is eighth a12 4. requires anyone
who meets that also that me that
requirement of 20 000 gallons a day or
600 000 gallons over a course of a month
to to get a a water quality certificate
that has been the law for at least 20 or
30 years
um and it generally has has worked well
what this bill does is it makes it clear
that the way that the current law
references that's that part of the
statute which actually sits in our clean
in our Drinking Water Act
is that it applies to that entire
provision
there are other parts of that provision
that really aren't applicable to the
surface water withdrawals as we sort of
have been doing them over the last 20 or
30 years so we've drawn that language
out so it's specific to what we're
actually talking about so it really does
get to this point that if it's a large
surface water withdrawal then you do
need to get again synonymous with the
groundwater program that you would need
to go and get a water quality
certificate this is quite common we do
this on snow making we've done this on
Industrial operations
um if you're up in Thornton the the
Eagles Nest sorry Owls Nest development
has one of these that we've just gone
through you know it's it is a pretty
common procedure we've done this on for
municipalities under large ground large
surface water withdrawals
so the point of this and the reason why
we want we look at these is because if
you're taking if you have a garden hose
that you're sucking some water out of
the Merrimack River it's no big deal
right it's a lot it's a little bit of
water out of a large water body
what also though happens is the opposite
we have a fire hose coming out of a
small stream or pond
and that's the kind of those are the
projects that do need to be looked at so
that we don't destroy those ecosystems
and I guess the final word I would have
on that is the reason why 20 000 gallons
per day or six hundred thousand gallons
per month is in statute and has been
there for a very long time is to
eliminate this requirement on homeowners
on individual homeowners or even a few a
small development and also on most
agricultural users
so most agricultural users also fall
below that that threshold so that was
the reason for that number that's why
it's in statute that's how it was
developed that's why it's been in in
play for so many years
what I would also just say and I know
that there's been some concerns
expressed about that about limiting
things like dust control uh on
construction projects is that we have
very frequently offered and have done
temporary withdrawal certificates so if
somebody has a big project a big Highway
project that they're trying to get done
they need for a summer to have some dust
control they've identified a water
supply we would work with them and I
think in our new rules we're going to
set up a process whereby we have almost
like a permit by notification sort of
thing so that people can be able to
withdraw under those conditions for very
temporary bases and so I'm gonna you may
hear more about that today but that's
something that the department would be
willing to work with uh any any of the
stakeholders on
finally um I'm going to pull the the
last piece of this is that it provides
I'm going to just cut to number six on
these I will talk about the other ones
if you want well just briefly on number
four
this is um public notifications
currently there's no nothing in statute
that says we have to do public
notifications or public hearings we have
done these by by tradition
but this is important to the people out
in the public have the ability to
comment on these important projects
water conservation rules again currently
large groundwater withdrawals anybody
taking from a large groundwater
withdrawal is required to have a water
conservation plan this is common sense
you shouldn't be wasting the state's
resources the common trust resources so
this applies right now to groundwater
withdrawals
um it should and then we have actually
been applying it to large water
withdrawals the statute is a little bit
vague on that but it also applies
anywhere where we have an in-stream flow
program which is on the designated
Rivers we've done five rivers so far so
it already applies to a whole bunch of
water users this makes it clear it
applies to all of those that have a
surface water permit and then the last
piece which Senator great spoke about
so several years ago this was put into
statute that we could not use a
particular statistic to calculate
nutrient effluent limits from wastewater
treatment plants
what we discovered and that was done in
good faith nobody quite understood that
we thought it was a not a we thought it
was a nothing sandwich at the time
it turns out it's a something sandwich
and really what it does is it limits the
flexibility of some of the wastewater
treatment plants in the state to be able
to have a certain limitation on their on
their nutrient effluent from the
wastewater treatment plants
if we take this away
some of the communities in the state a
few of them might get a little bit lower
but if we if we if we take it away
there's a whole bunch of communities
which will probably get more strict
regulations on their wastewater
treatment that would be very expensive
we are not convinced that that's
necessary from an environmental
standpoint so again
I know that I've dragged you now for
several minutes down the path of Arcane
bureaucratic water quality regulation
but this is a seriously important one
relative to how we regulate and build
wastewater treatment plants in the state
nutrient treatment is extraordinarily
expensive you can ask Rochester about
that
this what we are also doing is about to
to promulgate some new 1700 rules that
are water quality standards
by making this change in the statute we
will be able to make those rules more
flexible for permatease
so that was a whole mouthful that was a
lot of stuff I'm happy to work with you
I've also identified a couple of
different amendments in the uh in our
letter one of those amendments has to do
with what I suggested about making sure
that we don't get caught into a bind on
the timing issue the other is making
sure that there's time for applicants to
be able to respond to Des without
running out of time and so those are the
couple of the things that we identified
after this was put forward and I'm happy
to to answer any questions that you have
um and and if you uh on the Amendments
if you wish to have a subcommittee and
I'm happy to work with that subcommittee
so I'll stop there and um and see if I
have
if I've left you speechless or if uh if
there's questions today thank you so
much
thank you Mr news for taking my
questions it's a short one these
amendments you proposed had you propose
them to the senate or did they come to
your mind afterwards thank you for
asking that question this came after the
Senate hearings too late to be able to
get them into the Senate
okay
representative Darby
thank you Mr Trevor thank you for taking
my question I'm I'm sorry I just didn't
get that number six which is section
seven I don't unders can you sure
describe the flexibility
um that it provides how it reduces the
cost um communicabalities and why that's
safe
absolutely
so
I'm going to take Rochester because
Rochester is sort of the the the reason
why this provision was put in this
provision has only existed in state law
for four years
five years 18 I guess that's five years
time flies
um so the reason that was put in was
because when EPA was looking at
Rochester's
um wastewater treatment plant permit
which they're still working on that
wastewater treatment plant permit
the way that EPA has calculated
the the nutrients is that they look at a
certain flow statistic 7q10 is a flow
statistic it's the it's the lowest
it's the lowest seven days the lowest
week of flow in a 10-year period
so you take all the flows that we've
ever measured across time and we we
calculate this to this statistic out of
them which we identify the lowest flow
seven days in a row
um over a 10-year period
and so it's a common statistic used in
flow calculations and where this comes
from is we usually use it for looking at
toxicity issues so it's a low flow that
that's it's basically the definition of
a low flow
that doesn't happen very often but if
you're a critter and it's a toxic
substance that's going into the water
during those low flow periods you would
be bumming because it could be could be
killer for you
so that has been applied to nutrients
over time
and what they've done is they've
basically set an in-stream Target
for nutrients at a hundred micrograms
per liter for for we're really talking
about phosphorus here nutrients nitrogen
has a whole different pathway this is
really about phosphorus and so those of
you who who work in the phosphorus World
representative wrong
um that that this is that this is one
way in which we look at that and this is
PR this really has to do with rivers it
doesn't really have to do with the Lakes
foreign
so the way that a flow the way that the
the effluent would be calculated for
Rochester would be what would be the
effluent that they would need to put out
that would meet a hundred micrograms per
liter in the river so that the river
would measure 100 micrograms per liter
of phosphorus
under these low flow conditions
and this became problematic in the
permitting world because Rochester
believed that this would uh create an
onerous situation for them in terms of
in terms of
basically having to add additional
components to their wastewater treatment
plant
so what they were asking for
um well so they so they wanted so they
did away with it so that they so that
that couldn't happen unfortunately that
didn't really do away with it because
EPA writes the permit so EPA continued
to use 7q10 and 100 anyway
but what we're doing and this has been
in deep concert consultation with
Rochester and other communities in the
state and in fact their Consultants
helped us to create some of the rules
that we're now going to be proposing and
they've seen those rules and they're
very pleased with them and that's what
Senator gray was referring to is that
his communities have seen the rules that
we intend to do which would allow the
flexibility for communities that benefit
from the 7q10 and 100 as well as people
like Rochester who would like to propose
an alternative method
so this allows us to have our cake and
eat it too because there are communities
that do very well under the 7q 10 and
100 simply because of the geology and
the way that their watersheds and what
the way that the River statistics work
within their particular River
this is a little complex this is this is
water quality uh 400 at this point but
that is really that's the way that this
that's why this is important and that's
why taking this out allows the
flexibility so that we don't somehow
penalize other communities and provide
Rochester and and similar situations
with some other alternative method in
order to be able to calculate their
effluent limits
did that make sense at all
glad somebody's up up to speed
uh
I got a question yes sir all right first
they got an observation got this memo
last night I'm reading it and right in
the middle of it it says
uh
this creative sense the creation of sb60
the answer Des is recognized that
certain changes would improve the bill
and suggests the following changes be
incorporated well my question is okay
where's the amendment yeah so I'm happy
to send you that immediately an
amendment yeah yes so we have the
language the language of the amendment
is here this has all the language that
we would want is in the letter
um and I will send you a full version of
the bill that shows that it's just
because this bill is
what you when you see it you know it's
got cuts and and and tastes and and
strikeouts and I wanted to sort of
explain it to you before you saw the
amendment so that it would be more
and we're happy to work with OLS also if
there's any questions this is a rather
complicated bill and I don't do
complicated yes it's it's very I I
apologize it's again this is this is the
truly Arcane uh World in which we live
so
I saw you first I'm the chair
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr deers for taking
my question
it is a complicated bill
and
the big PowerPoint to get during the
hearing was the commissioner joining you
today it's like you said it's at Omnibus
Bill uh the commissioner has not joined
me today but we've had you know lots of
obviously this is lots and lots of
conversations about this
um and
so I'm not sure the commissioner is
fully supportive of this I'm not sure
what else you're you're quite asking
there so um
you've referred to a lot of rulemaking
yes to solve a lot of complicated
problems and a lot of folks have been
involved with rulemaking and right
they've got suggested rulemaking here
and there and other folks have seen the
proposed rules for rulemaking
can we see those rules absolutely we're
still in the process of crafting them so
they're not you know totally ready yet
but we are in the process of doing that
you you all can certainly you know we'll
we'll share we can certainly share
um
when we have again I don't think we're
ready quite yet
uh with those rules they're still being
crafted so I don't think it includes all
of the aspects that would be in this
bill yet
further question for a follow-up
so if a lot's being solved in rulemaking
and it's a complex bill and we just got
to look at some of the amendment or we
haven't seen the amendment yet maybe we
should
retain this and until we see some of
those rules and
get a better look at what's going on
what I would like to share with you is
that certainly on that item number six
which we have rules fully crafted on
that particular piece so I would be very
happy to share that piece with you
because that absolute that's really the
one piece that is highly dependent
that's where the only piece that in
which the rules are highly dependent on
this
are dependent on this and because we're
going to be moving those forward
immediately to EPA and there's some
people around the state with other
aspects that are in 1700 rules namely
aluminum and arsenic which are very
important to other uh other people in
the state we need to move those forward
that particular piece about number six
is the piece that's most dependent on
rules and so that's the piece that I
would I'm absolutely prepared today to
send around to you
further question
are is any of this
um
is any of this Senate Bill 60
or
the subsequent rulemaking
does that even have a direct impact on a
imminent Public Health
emergency or anything that
can't
wait a bit to get it right and put some
of those rules in statute like I I
personally favor statute over right
rulemaking that we like rule making to
be named later yeah so so the thing
that's a great question it's a great
question I would just say that again
from there's two different rule sets
we're talking about maybe this is what's
confusing it's confusing to me it's
confusing it's just we haven't seen any
of it and it's sort of to be determined
that makes me nervous so there's two
different rule sets one the rule said is
as real said around 401 certifications
and that's nothing in there at this
point except that I've talked about
maybe some ways of of talking about some
of the things that people might be
concerned about in this bill
everything else has been put into
statute there's nothing that's not in
statute here so the only pieces that
would go into the particular 401
certification piece would be the the the
administrative trappings of how this all
gets put into place
we don't have that currently the those
rules do not exist currently so
everything that's in statute today is is
really the only things that would be
there and would be administrative pieces
there's no limitations there's no
specific numbers in there that piece is
really just the administrative process
side
when do you apply what's the form you
apply on those kinds of things
the 1700 rules which are the water
quality standards which is provision
number six that actually has
implications today on permits that are
being written by EPA so that is a piece
that that really does need to get pushed
through and again that's a piece in
which we're we the rules are written I'm
happy to share those and we're prepared
to share those so again I think sort of
two separate issues that I don't think
are there's not dependency on rules
thank you sure representative wrong did
you have a question
I have a couple Mr chair thank you and
thank you very much Mr dears for taking
my question absolutely
um on uh page one of the bill line
five and six it talks about discharge
complies with the state service water
quality standards applicable to the
classification for the receiving surface
water body
do we have discharges I mean receiving
surface water body are those just Rivers
do we discharge into lakes as well is
that just pertinent to wastewater
treatment discharge thank you for asking
the question
the 401 program largely
it relates to rivers and wastewater
treatment plants both private and public
wastewater treatment plants
we have
um we don't have wastewater treatment
plants that discharge to Lakes okay
those have been phased out over the
years for obvious reasons like turning
Winnipesaukee green is a good reason to
not have your wastewater treatment plant
that was the impetus for building the
the Winnipesaukee River Basin project it
was to take that that waste and be able
to treat it and put very clean water
back into the Winnipesaukee River and
then into the Merrimack so that there
that it really very we have very very
few projects that ever in the 401 world
would trigger something that would go to
a lake
um from a from a discharge perspective
now there are other projects that
um would have such a large Wetland
impact
such a large Wetland impact that they
would stimulate a uh a wetland permit
from the Army Corps an individual permit
there we would do a water quality cert
and we would look at all of those issues
and if it happened to be drainage to a
lake we would be looking at that in the
context of the lake
okay follow up with okay so when we talk
about receiving surface water body that
that's primarily almost always Rivers
but it can include Wetlands if they
drain into a lake okay and then I have
another question
um on page two of the bill on line 14.
um the language or diversion of surface
water has been removed
do you know why that is is being removed
from the bill yes that's a great
question thank you for picking that up
this again comes back to let's just uh
Rochester appears to be my my Victim of
choice today
um sorry Senator
um but uh the Seacoast is common that so
example in Rochester they take water
from one uh Reservoir and send it to
another Reservoir based on the water
conditions that are going on in those
particular places
we don't want something like that
because it's been going on forever or
even if it was new it's still going from
just one reservoir to another we don't
want that to stimulate a permitting
process
so so that's one of the reasons why
we've put this language directly into
the statute here that comes and this
actually comes out again comes out of
the Clean Water the clean Drinking Water
Act statute we put it directly here so
that it doesn't somehow implicate other
things like a diversion and so we want
to make sure that this is very clear
it's specific to that particular thing I
got it all right because that I I just
want to make sure that we recognize
water diversion as an important
consideration and permitting absolutely
it is always but but in this case you
wouldn't want to do that because it
could cause weird permitting things to
happen Okay and a final question Mr
chair
thank you
um when you talk about the water quality
certification and could you go into what
is actually measured for to determine
water quality sure to comply with the
certification requirements yeah
absolutely so um I'll pick on dot a
little bit
um just because it's fun but um the uh
so they would sometimes get 401
certifications for large Highway
projects and one of the one of the water
quality uh standards that we have which
is quite common that this is the
discussion we have is around turbidity
so they have projects that are are
creating you know runoff as they're
doing their projects and then subsequent
to that there they have you know
drainage Pro they have a whole drainage
system that has a storm water treatment
systems all of that as well as all the
work components that are going on at the
time
our water quality standard for for New
Hampshire says that you can't have a
turbidity that's higher than 10 what's
called ntus above background
and so when dot proposes a large project
like this and it has this 404 permit
we're making sure that they're all of
those kinds of best management practices
that they've designed to treat the water
and to make sure that during
construction that they're not going to
have a turbidity problem that those are
that those are certified those the way
that they're doing it the plans that
they're using the other permits that
they've gotten are what's going to meet
water quality standards so that the
people of New Hampshire can be sure that
that water quality standard will be met
while this project is going on and
afterwards
that's really how this plays out and so
we would be looking at their engineering
plans we would be looking at the other
permits that they've gotten and we would
say Yep they're covered and that's
largely how it works is yup they've done
a really good job they're covered for
this and then we're looking at all of
the other water quality standards we
would have as well but that's a good
example of how this would work okay
you have not asked a question yet
representative wolf thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking it
um this is a huge bill although it's
only you know a couple of pages you get
going on the thing it's huge does it pay
to break it apart and
deal with each session somewhat to Mr
what Mr McHugh representative McHugh was
saying
um
Bring It Forward in different sections
so that we can get some of those things
that you're talking about that are in
process completed maybe not do those now
and do the parts that you need to do
I guess for Rochester right now
so I think it's a great question
um
it's not a horrible idea I think that
I want you all to be very comfortable
with what you're passing and so if there
are pieces parts that we'd like to break
apart I'm certainly willing to entertain
that and we can have a conversation
about how that might go go forward so if
that's if that is how the committee
wants to go eventually you know I don't
think that that's a problem we can come
back with other parts of this in the
next session
um you know I think that that's fine
there are some parts that I think were
important and that you know I think
again I want to make sure that everyone
is comfortable and understands the bill
because
um
in general we think that these are sort
of housekeeping things
but it sounds big when you see the whole
thing on in paper and so I think we'd
man make sure that everyone is
comfortable with that
um however that approach takes place
thank you I just say at this point I'm
not comfortable with what I'm saying
you're not comfortable you should be
where I sit
representative therapy all right thank
you Mr chair thanks for the question
taking my question I yeah same
same question for me like um so you
talked about
um two sets of rules and it seems like
the rules of 1700 are important are
those the rules that are described in
one more brief for a follow-up thank you
Mr chair
um
is there any reason why the proposed
amendments that you've laid out in this
memo couldn't be taken up next year
thank you for the question if if I were
to to break this apart at this moment
what I would do is I would take Section
I would take the the the number one and
the number six and move those forward
now
the number one is really important
because it allows us to do those waivers
and that's really to both an applicant's
um that's really to an applicant's favor
and so I think if if I were to move
something forward it would be the number
that number one piece which is
um which is what um which is line nine
of page one of the bill
and then I would move forward
um
I would move forward uh that number six
piece which is 11 and 12 of page four of
the bill
so if we were going to break this apart
in that way that's how I would go about
doing it because I think that that key
hits the key pieces that are really
I I'm when you're using the numbers off
your spread to your sheet but not using
the sections I will use the sections on
my on your sheet I apologize because
that makes more sense yeah it's actually
the bill
um so it would be section one which is
the enforcement of classification
section
and
um section seven
huh seven section seven that's why it's
confusing section seven which is line 24
of Page Three okay
okay but but I thought that you were
saying that the 1700 rules which are
covered in section yes
yes so six is seven I'm sorry so six is
section seven in here I wrote it as
number six in my notes to you so section
six is not necessarily that important
the rules for water conservation not
important right now if yeah because I
well I mean they are important that's
why we put them in the bill but I want
to make sure everyone's comfortable with
that if you're looking asking for what's
really essential out of this bill it's
sections one and seven thank you thank
instead of Donnelly
uh real brief thank you for taking my
question uh what's the benefit of
keeping it all together and not breaking
it out because you clearly put it
together I'm just curious you know right
the benefit and I think again with
respect to um the questions that have
come up about rulemaking and I do
respect those very much
is that we're gonna it helps to inform
all the rules that we're going to be
doing simultaneously that that's the
advantage of doing all this now is that
it kind of gets it in a place where we
can now move forward quickly
so I I think we but again
No One's Gonna
uh you know no one's gonna die if we if
we break these apart so if we need to
hold off on that I'm fine with that and
again we can separate the bill into a
couple pieces
so it certainly has an advantage for the
Department in that we can create a whole
cogent set of rules based on changes in
statute that makes it a lot easier for
us to do that but I understand that
people want to kind of understand how
[Music]
through some of
some permits
how does it help the end
uh contractor the end consumer the end
people how does it help having
everything in one bill sure versus
splitting it out I understand from you
is it been more beneficial for you as
Des or is it more than it does it
actually help the end uh consumer yeah
that's a great question I I would say
that the the middle sections of this
bill primarily help the the permittee
they lay out a cogent set of ways that
people are going to move forward through
this process they lay out time frames
they make it less likely that someone
would be able to appeal based on time
frames so so yes it does have we think
that most of these will have a benefit
to the the applicant themselves
especially the timing pieces the timing
pieces will have a benefit especially as
the federal government also is changing
its 401 rules to make sure that what we
have in place will uh will make sure
that that that's going to work with the
federal rules so yeah there's a benefit
of course
um
so however we want to go through that
but I want to make sure that this is
successful in getting through the
committee
um that there's a good understanding of
what this is in the committee and that
everyone can be you know supportive of
it I think that's really important
right okay my problem is I got to figure
out how to get this built through here
and right now I I'm clueless
we have a whole lot of various
issues sure
parts of this bill
and also there's a part of the bill like
an amendment coming that we haven't even
seen yet
so we're just going to go around in a
circle for the rest of the day if we
continue
so we if I would then I'm just trying to
doing it off the top of my head wherever
and
we
we maybe should be looking to uh
continue
the this hearing at some future date
uh maybe uh I think we have some time
from nine o'clock to
10 10 30 but should we either a recessed
of the committee commission to the the
committee or for this hearing to to then
or
on this uh
on this bill
just to see how to see what we can
if we can you know cut the salami up
into right so we can eat so that we can
eat this
uh
presenter wolf you have a
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm hearing that there are some parts of
this bill that are more important that
should be dealt with sooner rather than
later
am I correct on that yes thank you I
think that that's I think that that's a
good assessment so
follow up
what if that is in fact true
I'm wondering whether
you could figure out a way to break it
into two pieces and come back at the
work session in arts well we could do we
could do that at that work session
because I'm talking about next I'm
talking about next week we have
we have we have time if so the the
probably an hour and a half from nine
o'clock to 10 30 to be able to do
something
representative thank you Mr chair I am
in full support of having a work session
is that of harm
Mr chairman I'd like to know if there's
anybody else here that was going to
speak on this bill before you decide to
continue I don't I don't have anybody
else okay is there anything else anyone
else but that is a good good point
anywhere else uh wish to speak on this
bill
not to say it uh
nine o'clock uh
nine to ten and I say nine to ten thirty
because we do have a 10 30 Bill uh
do that
it was to hear after that
is that okay I mean obviously I'm just
ERS
I'll tell you that you did just say that
uh
yeah yes if you have any comments maybe
you can
possibly yeah if we could probably call
in or something
any other comments on the
we we do have by the way a uh another
set of you know we are having a session
on the uh the 19th but it was good but
was going to start at 10 30 but it'll
start in case you want to do something
for 29 and 9 30 we're going to do this
work session at 9 30.
uh that gives you a half an hour if you
we'll we'll talk about it right now
we've got to get it we've got to get the
man got to get the uh the uh
Hearing in and we also need the copy of
the amendment yes
uh any any other comments uh
that's true comment
um I just wanted to comment that the
Department of Transportation might want
to be here for that and I know notice
that they should be a work session
anybody can come thank you
uh there are public hearings
thank you Mr chair I appreciate this
opportunity to be able to have further
discussions on this bill
what I would like to do perhaps is in
advance I'll send kind of the whole bill
with some with the proposed amendments
that are in our letter yep what I will
also do is
um
well why don't I do that that'll provide
the ability to be able to have that
conversation and then what I would also
do is present I'll send around our
current draft of the parts of the 1700
rules that would be affected by that
last section of this bill I think that
that would be also helpful so you see
that this is that that piece is for
reals uh we have that that already
crafted so we can have that for you and
then we can be prepared to talk about
any of the other aspects and I think
having the entire
um you know having entire piece in front
any other questions any other comments
if not I will uh actually I can uh I
think I can adjourn because we will be
going to a
work session so that'll be good
I adjourn the uh during the hearing
now
um
foreign
is yours good morning again Mr chairman
uh members of the committee Senator
David Waters District Four to introduce
Senate Bill 123 relatively adoption of
ambient groundwater quality standards by
the Department of Environmental Services
this comes before uh the committee as a
request of the commissioner of Des and
it does two things
um
first it corrects an internal
inconsistency in existing statute
regarding the criteria the department
has to use when establishing or amend an
ambient groundwater quality
standards and if you look at the
existing statute you see that in one
place it says that
the standards shall be equivalent to any
State Maximum containment level
but also says that it should be at least
astringent as any
Federal advisory so complying with this
wouldn't be possible if the state
uh level is less stringent than the
federal health advisory which is a
realistic possibility and given the way
these advisories come out so you'll see
um online's uh 9 through 12 here the
language is corrected to make that
um consistent so that
um we'll have the state standards
that will be equivalent
but then we could adopt more more
stringent ones if we wish
the second part of the bill gives the
required flexibility to the commissioner
on evaluating those Health advisories
from the federal government
the existing statute said issued
or published
and we want to change that to adopt it
because that will give the Commissioners
the flexibility and the option to
determine whether or not it makes sense
both for a health purpose or for a
financial cost
issue
to adopt those Federal standards so
that's what the bill does
um I think that you know in a sense it's
technical but it also I think
importantly
recognizes the flexibility that Des
needs our department as you know has
been such a leader when it comes to pfas
and other harmful chemicals and trying
to protect our citizens our children and
so forth and this will be an important
ability for the commissioner to really
to be able to do the job without
being caught up in this inconsistency or
handcuffed by
occasionally inappropriate federal
statute so there it is Mr chairman and
then I do know that we have folks here
from Des okay thank you
seeing none thank you very much
recognize
it
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Mike
wimsat as service director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Des with me this joining me this morning
is Scott drew a project manager in our
house space remediation Bureau and I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
this morning in support of Senate bill
123. as Senator Waters indicated in his
introduction of the bill um the suit was
a request of the Department of
Environmental Services and we we fully
support the bill as amended by the
Senate
um essentially and I think Senator
Waters summarized it well we have a you
know RSA 45C is the groundwater
protection act and it basically provides
the authority and the and the uh
enabling legislation to allow Des to
address and oversee the cleanup of
contaminated sites in the state and one
of the fundamental parts of that is
having enforceable ambient groundwater
quality standards that apply to all
man-made contaminants that that may find
their way into the state's groundwater
and this bill would amend 45 C6 which is
a proportion of the the section of the
statute that dictates how we set those
aiming groundwater quality standards and
as the senator uh you know very
appropriately described there's an
internal inconsistency in that language
that we are very likely to see come
about it's not a theoretical one in in
the near term here
for those of you who follow the news
regarding pfas EPA just this spring
proposed new uh for the first time a
federally enforceable
drinking water mcl's maximum contaminant
levels for several pfas compounds and
all you use pfoa as an example because
it's a good example and it's the primary
contaminant that we see in Southern New
Hampshire as a result of a number of
releases that have occurred there and so
the proposed MCL for pfoa that EPA
published just four parts per trillion
and they haven't indicated that they
anticipate after the appropriate public
comment and review
finalizing that standard in probably
early 2024. meanwhile there's also an
interim Health advisory it's not a final
but it's an interim Health advisor that
EPA issued some time ago that is three
orders of magnitude lower than that it's
on the order of four parts per
quadrillion and if you look at the
language and and they have not finalized
that yet but we expect that they will
finalize that Health advisory in the
coming months or perhaps in the coming
year and if that were to happen it
exposes the internal inconsistency that
exists right now in 45 C6 because the
the law would have us you know basically
what happens is when they set a federal
MCL our drinking water program
typically adopts that Federal MCL so
let's say that happens and we then have
a state MCL of four parts per trillion
but then they finalize the health
advisory at four parts per quadrillion
and the statute tells us to use both of
those and obviously the three orders of
magnitude apart we we'd be in a quandary
to figure out what do we do at this
point so what this bill would do is
really make it very clear that the
Immigrant groundwater quality standard
is to be set equivalent to
the state MCL which we expect would
would be in line with the federal MCL
once it's finalized but it retains for
the commissioner when circumstances May
warrant the ability and the authority to
set a lower ambient groundwater quality
standard than that state MCL when
circumstances might dictate and that's
really it is as simple as that it's
really about addressing this
inconsistency so the Des knows what it
is we're supposed to do to comply with
the law once these standards are
finalized and with that I will be happy
to take any questions that you might
the committee
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
um thanks for the question
um in the um
Financial note it talks about
um
checking for a maybe it's or in the bill
checking for a lifetime exposure risk of
one cancer case in uh per 1 million
exposed population it's in the
maybe it's not the financial no maybe
that isn't the bill you're right it's
been built in the bill yeah and so I'm
just wondering how that's measured and
it and
um that's the law that that would be the
statute that the commissioner would have
to set the guidelines by yeah that is
existing law that is not essentially not
being changed with this amendment um
what what that's really saying is that
if um because the commissioner basically
has in in now and even with this
amendment retains discretion to make
judgment calls about what we know you
know use not just these standards that
have been set but also use information
that we have about the toxicology of a
particular contaminant and so the the
commission will retain the authority to
set the drinking the in ambient
groundwater quality standard based upon
a health advisory that is associated
with evaluating cancer risk so the
probably the best way to explain this is
that we we regulate a host of
contaminants with ambient groundwater
quality standards not all of those
contaminants have a federal or a state
drinking water MCL there are many of
them that don't have an MCL established
and so when we set those
one of the criteria that we can use is
well what's the federal health advisory
for that is there a health advisory for
it and in many cases those Health
advisories may be issued for different
reasons they may be for a health
endpoint that's related to cancer or it
could be about some other disease that
isn't cancer so in the case where they
establish it based on a cancer risk for
a con for a compound or contaminant
that's believed to be cancer-causing
EPA will use actually a range of cancer
risks they'll use a one in ten thousand
excess cancer risk of 100
000 or one in a million and what our law
has said for many years and we've and
it's how we've implemented it is when we
are setting a standard based on a health
advisory that is related to cancer we're
going to set it at that one in one
million excess cancer risk so this just
that that part doesn't change with
respect to this this amendment
last question myself
one part in a quadrillion
well
um the short answer is you don't right
now with respect to
um
with respect to pfas
um the the the
reliable commercially available
Laboratories who have done amazing work
in the last seven years to really bring
their game to a very low level of
detection they can reliably detect
usually around one part per trillion and
Report one to two parts per trillion
they can report that and they can have
some you know expectation that it's a a
reliable number below that
um it's just not
I'm not saying it won't get there
it's not to be argumentative but they're
establishing a standard
our oath by using it sure well to be
fair what EPA has proposed with their
federal drinking water MCL is four parts
per trillion which absolutely can be
measured and in many respects that
number I think is in partment selected
by EPA because they believe it to be
across the board nationally a number of
the Laboratories that are doing this
work on drinking water can absolutely
detect and Report accurately
so um the poor part per quadrillion
number is is not an enforceable standard
it's never been intended to be that it's
a health advisor that has really a whole
lot of other considerations that go into
setting that and it's not intended to be
a standard that would be enforced on a
public drinking water system or
something like that it's intended to be
guidance that can be used by
toxicologists and regulators and Risk
Managers to make decisions about a whole
host of things including what do we do
when we're cleaning up a site you know
what do we shoot for and you know one of
the problems with with pfas is that you
know the the latest information that EPA
is released with their proposed MCL
suggests that it's it's potentially
toxic and could have health effects at
very very low concentrations so their
their their health advisory reflects
that analysis but then when they look at
how they're going to regulate public
water systems they have to look at not
only that but you know they have to set
a standard that people can actually test
for and demonstrate that they they can
meet and they do there's a whole host of
work they release 2 800 pages of
analysis and backup information when
they propose this MCL and people all
over the country including DS are
reviewing that pretty carefully now and
and we'll be participating in the public
thank you thank you very much I don't
see any other questions or any other
we have no other uh
no other ticket
uh
you think maybe that this might be
something we might want to
you might want to
[Music]
exec right now
I'm just throwing it out
is anybody comfortable with doing that
are you okay with huh yeah is it
Anonymous or should we caught it oh uh I
mean among the the 10.
uh
if you knew if you need to caucus we can
just pull this you know it doesn't just
do it
what are you doing everyone yeah not
putting not putting any pressure on
anybody and I and as far as I'm you know
as far as I'm concerned if one person
says they're not comfortable then it's I
would no one should save it then we'll
save it
yeah
you got 10 minutes she wants to take two
minutes to think about yeah if you let
us you know we
we can go
yeah we will when is it what's this
one's 11 15. so if you're
if you want you want to leave the room
compartment
s you want it she's okay you're okay
I just lost the clerk okay
yes I mean yeah we can we have a we've
never used this one just texted me he's
yeah
right well well we won't we'll uh we
won't I won't shut the meeting down yeah
as I won't adjourn it we'll we'll go
right into executive session and uh as
she comes back
oh
we can take this back uh let's see
uh just in reading this
uh well the it looks it looks like the
the entire delegation from uh
from Merrimack is on this bill
or at least all that could fit on the
so
don't know yes I'll look for uh look for
a move well
representative rung is on the bill yeah
I move that we ought to pass on uh house
uh Senate bill 123fn
seconded by representative Healy is
there any discussion on is is there any
discussion on
representative Vale
thank you Mr chair I'm delighted to be
able to exec this bill today I think
it's really important and I appreciate
the sponsors for putting this forward
thank you Mr chair
may have I apologize representative rung
I should recognize you first as the
making of the motion you wish to speak
on your motion
um no I support this bill as a
co-sponsor
um I think it's important that our
statutes are consistent and we don't
federal law doesn't create uh conflicts
within our own statute so this I look at
representative Haley which to speak on
your second it's just what she said Good
Housekeeping and just keep up with the
are you ready sir well this they haven't
included the usual paper
all right I am Renita okay all right
and Senate Bill 123 FN will the clerk
please call the roll
and an emotion of uh uh on the motion of
uh to pass representative heart yes
representative Goulds yes representative
Horrigan yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf
representative McHugh
yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly
is uh wait a minute Kelly's not here
okay yeah
representative Simpson
which is not here either okay
representative Darby
yes representative white yes
representative lamentane yes
representative Lovett
I'm not here not here and representative
Ryan yes and representative Zulu yes
okay
that is 17 years zero Nays motion passes
if and we I will adjourn the executive
session on
I've been said consent yes okay
that's right
foreign
daughter on Senate bill
229 relative to administration of
certain Wetland permits by the
Department of Environmental Services
nope
thank you
um Mr chair and members of the committee
um Jeb Bradley
from wolfbro Senate District 3 and
pleased to be here and sponsor of
Senate bill 229. I was asked to
um file this bill
by the Department of Environmental
Services
um
I did
and the purpose of the bill is to make
certain technical changes
to Wetlands criteria the department is
here they can testify to them if you
have specific questions but
um it adds a 10 cent per square foot
disturbance associated with the
amendment request it doesn't add that it
um
clarifies it
it allows the department to Grant an
extension of the 120 day time period
um
and it clarifies the jurisdictional
levels and then
um
representative McConkey asked me
starting in section four to add criteria
for
um rebuilding
uh septic systems
in New Hampshire
to make sure that when someone replaces
the septic system they can use the
original design and that
um
the plans if they're missing uh can
revert back to Prior State approvals so
those are the conditions of this bill as
it passed the Senate the one thing that
is not in this bill the department had
asked me to put in a provision that
sought to change a Supreme Court
ruling on
rebuilding non-conforming structures
within the 100 or I believe the 50-foot
setback of the Shoreland protection act
that proved to be pretty controversial
to the Senate it was my recommendation
that it be removed I think that
um
there needs to be
an agreement between property owners and
quite frankly it was the Realtors who
brought the concern to me and the
department on protecting pre-existing
rights
um and not overturning a Supreme Court
decision and adding new regulations on
pre-existing structures and I think
that's something that needs to be
negotiated and brought back in a another
piece of legislation at some point in
time in the future so that is not in
this bill it was in the original version
of the bill so thank you
any questions from the center
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um regarding the um this section for
um with subsection or A1 talks about
accessory dwelling units and it
specifically calls out one accessory
dwelling unit I I wonder if that's
because that's you know what's in the
law in RSA 67472 and I wonder if 67472
should 72 should be referenced instead
of spelling it out the one explicitly
there
I'm not sure I can answer that question
I I inserted this language directly as
representative McConkey who is a septic
designer asked me to do
um and as I as I said the the whole idea
behind it was to make sure you could
rebuild the septic system based on the
original approved version of it for
any other questions
cription
all right
um
good morning chairman rizzulo and
members of the committee
for the record my name is Philip
Trowbridge I'm the manager of the land
resource management programs
at New Hampshire Des
land resource management programs
includes Wetlands permitting alteration
of terrain permitting and subsurface
systems Bureau permitting which is
septic systems
so thank you for this opportunity to
testify and Senate Bill 229 the
department supports this bill because it
fixes several small issues in the
statutes related to the permitting
programs that can create ambiguity or
difficulty for applicants
our program the program that I ever see
handles over 10 000 permits a year and
the vast majority of these go very
smoothly and there's there's no issues
but because we handle such a high volume
every once in a while we come across
little glitches that create
complications and to keep track of those
and this bill is a compilation of those
where we think this these fixes will
make things easier for applicants
four parts of the bill
the first two parts pertain to the
alteration of terrain statute and they
clarify how to calculate fees in these
rare instances where someone is coming
in to amend a previous application the
statute it's just a little bit unclear
on that right now it some people think
it reads that we should charge this fee
based on the total area of impact of the
whole project
whereas the intent was really to just
charge it on the new impact for the
amendment so it's just like making sure
that that's clear to people
and then obviously we want to give
people time
to respond to questions if we have them
the Wetland statute has that
um
we just think it should also be in the
alteration of training statute
uh the third part of the bill it relates
to Wetlands and this is again a rare
case situation
very rarely you have an applicant who
comes in and they have a property that
spans a town boundary
and they're they're the rules are
written or the statue is written now
that they have to notify the town and so
now they're dealing with two towns and
two uh Town clerks and two local
conservation commissions so this is just
clarifying that it you would deal with
the town where your impacts are actually
occurring
uh
and finally the fourth part of the bill
pertains to this repair and replacement
for income in-kind perceptic systems
and there's there's three changes here
uh one is we
put some clarification as to what a
domestic sewage is because this
provision was put in only for domestic
wastes uh but that's not defined
anywhere and that's led to some
confusion where people will come in and
try and use this portion of the bill for
or this part of the law
for like an apartment building
replacement
um or a condominium replacement and
those are much more complicated systems
they often have multiple owners it
really wasn't meant for that and that's
why we mentioned you know single family
dwelling with one Adu
um
second part was to ask for to submit the
prior State approvals which is a
requirement for the to use this
provision
in advance
this may seem like more work for the
applicant but in reality we've had a lot
of cases where people go ahead and do
the work that they need that they think
they're authorized to do when they don't
actually have their approvals the old
prior approvals and then they run into a
circumstance where they can't finish the
work and they have to come to us to do
applications couldn't even do a full
application and there's a lot of delays
it also helps the contractor because
they know that they have the actual
final plan and they're building things
um and then I'll to kind of mitigate
some of the you know extra work on that
we're allowing the source of that plan
to be uh broader than just the state or
town records uh that the designers who
designed the original system can now
provide that information and because
they often have records and there are
there are known gaps in our archives
from times when you know records were
lost due to leaks and buildings and
things so we know that sometimes we need
to rely on the designers to get that
information
so that's those are all the pieces of
the bill what these all have in common
is that they're purely administrative
they don't reduce or expand
Environmental Protections
they will make it easier for applicants
and their contractors and they won't
increase costs to the applicants the
state or Municipal governments
so thank you for the opportunity I'm
representative run
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
um I actually have two questions but my
primary question is
um on the the part of the bill which
addresses septic systems
um up until a bill that we passed I
believe last year there were certain
people that were allowed to submit their
own septic system designs without having
to go through estate approval if I think
I'm understanding that correctly so with
this sort of waiver of having a new
design approve apply to them because
there may be
septic systems that are in place that
should not have been approved but
they're in is there a way for those
designs to be reconsidered before
they're able to waive approval for a
replacement
very good thanks for the question
representative wrong
um the the bill you're referring to last
year it removed the requirement uh well
it removed the ability for someone to
design their own system
however they could just even when that
was in place they still needed approval
from the Department to you know of that
design
so the circumstance where someone has
built a faulty design
didn't come to the state at all and then
now is seeking to replace it that
shouldn't exist because we had to
approve their design and the reason we
passed that bill last year is it
normally takes us a very long time to
get to an agreed upon design
um and so the design that we approved is
suitable for replacement
okay
a follow-up question Mr chair
so
so if if an existing design is going to
be applied to a replacement system
is there any consideration for the
reasons why that that system may have
failed in the first place that maybe it
just wasn't an issue of the natural
decline of the system that there could
have been some other
element that caused that failure that
should be taken into consideration
before
a new system is replaced a new system is
constructed
yeah all right thank you for the
question
um the
determining the cause of a septic system
failure is is extremely complicated
because it it deals with a question of
the use of the system and what may have
been put into it it can deal with uh
um you know that the original design or
the technology that was used
um so if there's a really obvious cause
of the failure that's to be you know
that's determined and that's I think
factored into what people would want to
do next
um but the mass majority
the no one knows exactly why
one thing to know about this repair and
replacement
and kind option is it can only be done
once
so it's if someone's put in a septic
system and then it fails they can use
this repair replacement in kind you know
option just one time and if it fails
again then they have you know we have to
come in for a whole new design that's
where a greater consider you know maybe
any other questions by members of the
committee
instead of Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question it so it sounds like you're
familiar with the language regarding the
adu's
um in section four
um the the RSA I referenced 674-72
specifically is about adus on you know
single-family dwellings and so
um
and the for example there was a bill
this year that that failed in the house
that said oh we want to increase the
number of adus that are allowed if the
septic supports it right so that would
have updated to 674.72 and then it would
have been inherited if that were
if that were supported rather than
having to amend this as well that's my
that's why my question is should this
reference the accessory dwelling units
as
um as stated for single-family
residences in 674-72
all right thank you for the question
representative Darby I think that's a
very good point we did look at 674 as we
sorry as we were working on this
language because we felt that we should
include accessory going units in this
and not just say that it only applied to
single family dwellings because more and
more houses have adus and then an Adu
had the uh talking about an edu was like
by that definition in 674 71 was that it
had a common ownership
and so that relieves any of the concerns
about dealing with multiple owners on
the property and we chose you know one
one Adu but if there's another part of
674 that says
you know something about the the number
of adus that could be there that's
something we could we could certainly
look at at you know cross referencing to
that
um
I don't know if at what point you know
if there'd be a large number of houses
with more than
one or two adus you know probably there
is a limit as to what this you know
could be held could the capacity do
to treat the waste on a on a house lot
anyone any other questions
separate a separate follow-up
um yeah so my question was
um thank you for the question again
um
in in section four again when the when
the approved plan is not available
um from the state you know you you
mentioned some cases where it's where
it's destroyed
um is there would Des check and say like
we do have this or not rather than sort
of just say okay we've you know
in in case somebody tried to say oh no
this was the original plan like is there
some kind of checks and balances there
correct thank you for the question and
that gets to the first
uh or the change in the middle part of
of the second page
um where we're asking for a copy of the
approved construction and operation
prior you know submitted with the
application and that is where we are
cross-checking to make sure that this
um what what plan has been submitted or
what approvals have been submitted how
are the most recent ones and then each
plan is a is assigned a number so that
if we have an approval and we know from
our databases that that's the most
recent approval that the the plan that
they're going to work off of is the plan
that was from that approval
so yeah and that's the case where you
know we have our databases we know that
this was approved on such a such a date
with this number but for whatever reason
the record the plan is missing
we can now that can be obtained from the
designer and it could be
cross-referenced by the plan number so
that we know that it corresponds to the
representative wrong thank you Mr chair
I'm still dwelling on the septic system
issue and uh
question I have so first of all I don't
see in the bill where it just gives that
one pass
do you know
sorry it's not in the bill it's in the
original statute which I don't have with
me oh the original statute allows for
the same design yeah
okay
try and find it
um if you just one minute yeah that's
okay
okay if you could look at um
in the middle of the page it's
uh there's a number number nine the
system has not been previously repaired
or replaced
okay I see it thank you and then one
other question
um is on line 16 of that same page it
says a system is not within 75 feet and
I know that's currently in statute but
I'm just curious why we have that 75
feet for a septic system but the
shoreline protection area is 250 feet
okay thank you for the question there's
there's a um if I could step back on
that Shoreline protection has uh several
about uh thresholds or setbacks there's
the 50-foot setback for uh vegetated
buffer and then is the 150 foot for
um in in spreadsheets sorry vegetative
buffer and also no primary structures
and then within 150 feet there's other
restrictions on fertilizer use and other
things and then within the full
protected Shoreline is 250 feet and that
deals with some storm water controls
okay so there's there's a gradation
there in Shoreland
the 75 feet setbacks were set in
subsurface for dealing with hydrology
and flows from a septic system to some
other water body
it's a 75 feet is the typical setback to
your drinking water well and that's been
determined that that's kind of the area
from which the well is drawing water and
that same setback was used for a lot of
the surface waters because it's it had
the same hydrologic flow characteristics
so they're kind of set they're you know
they were set for different reasons they
they don't
um they sh they don't need to match and
so you know they're there's a little bit
of a mismatch there but they they were
determined for the purposes that they
are intended
okay thank you can I just have one more
follow-up thank you but when a septic
system fails the primary
outcome of that would be is it runoff
from water with the Wastewater pooling
on the surface so would it be run off
into the surface water where you
wouldn't really have that kind of issue
with the well so the setback for a well
or other things
when it that that 75 feet or within 150
feet I'm just what I'm what I'm getting
at is I'm concerned about Septic Systems
Failing near surface water because the
outcome of that is going to be run off
of that septic fluid into the surface
water
for your question on that in
when a septic system fails a couple of
things can happen the definition is that
it's it's no longer adequately
containing or treating waste
so surface breakout is is the most
visible and common problem of that
you can have that occur within the
ground you know on subsurface uh when
the system is no longer treating any of
the waste but
the when the property changes ownership
on a Shoreland property it has to
undergo this evaluation to determine if
it's in Failure so there's a bit of a
fail space in terms of Fail-Safe in
trying to determine that
for the most part if a system is in
Failure the other control that we have
on it is that it's considered a
non-sanitary condition and the health
officer can take immediate action to
require replacement
so should a system go in Failure it
should not persist long because of the
health officer sanitary protection
authorities
seeing none
thank you very much all right thank you
very much
they have no additional cards anyone
I'll call the well yeah
before I call this one closed do uh
anybody
feel uncomfortable about disposing of
I I do
um Mr chair I I really want to go
through this whole septic thing again
okay thanks okay I think yeah
yeah I don't think I would use the that
this uh this device that we're doing
without total total uh
everybody everybody in
uh
can we because we closed the hearing on
I mean
I know we could I know we can do it
right at the end of the uh of the
hearing I'm not certain if we've closed
the hearing whether we can
yeah and I certainly wouldn't want to
wanna
usually could it doesn't hurt yeah so
what do we why don't we hold it I can
find it we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna hear we're gonna uh
yeah I mean we can
yeah so
okay I will close the uh the hearing on
and uh see you at one o'clock
yeah I was wondering for a while if we
were going to be on time but
yes
well it said at Bill six the evening
foreign
okay
but call the hearings order
they're
in the final bill on the agenda for
today
is Senate Bill 11 relative to
Laura is yours thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee here I am again
Senator David Waters District Four and
uh I'm introducing Senate Bill 11
relative African-American burial grounds
I'll go through the bill in a moment but
I I wanted to start by thanking you Mr
chairman members of the committee
because this came to you last year we
had a very thorough study committee
process on it and uh made some
recommendations for some needed changes
which were Incorporated in this version
of the bill and it did come out with a
20-0 vote from your committee
recommending
um reintroduction and so here I am to
reintroduce it I know you have some new
members of the the committee and I
certainly will be questions to refresh
the memory on it so I will walk through
it but perhaps not too extensively
um
so um this bill uh established the
principle recognizing the importance of
preserving African-American gravesites
Market associated
materials
um and when these sites are located uh
to be sure that we have document and try
to preserve them and to support efforts
to identify descendants if there are any
and then also to work with The
Descendant Community if we can't find
Millennial descendants
um and uh this is an issue of increasing
importance across the state as
continuing research has identified
dozens and dozens of these sites around
the around the state from people who
were enslaved in the in the state
um and uh that therefore local Cemetery
boards and others are looking to know
what to do and recognizing the kind of
distinctive situation that these burial
sites represent his historically
um I can point in a moment to a couple
of examples of this and why the help
that's outlined in this bill is most
welcome from our communities
um so you have some definitions of what
is this descendant community and it's
frankly recognizing that they're highly
unlikely that there are lineal
descendants that can be identified from
people who were enslaved they were
considered property at their time did
not have family rights were often buried
and kind of out of the way or or strange
places and their identities were kind of
in many ways erased until research has
now
recovered them this is not always the
case Samson Battis in Canterbury who
lived to the age of 105 dying in 18 102
at dying in 1852 as descendants uh today
who are still very president in the
state but that's a very rare
circumstance so it could be
African-American individuals riding in a
municipality or a designated represented
representative a group for example that
would be selected by the New Hampshire
division of historical resources that
would have some expertise in how to
handle these Graves respectively and
then the African-American grave is
refers particularly here who was likely
to have been alive during the period of
American
uh in enslavement
and um so then really in some ways
following existing statute if you go
into
um our Cemetery statute 289 you'll see
there are all kinds of procedures you
know what do you do if a backhoe comes
across a graveyard or if there's a
municipal construction project or other
kind where graveyard might be disturbed
or is Disturbed and has to be moved
which happens sometimes so you see that
that this really mirrors that statute
but it does add this
um particular
um uh provision that if this kind of
disturbance happens then you develop an
arrangement with a descendants or
descendant Community
um to do appropriate historical
documentation signage and mitigation of
the impacts on those on those uh sites
now if there needs to be removal which
does happen sometimes as I'm sure you
know
um then these remains should be examined
in a respectful manner as determined by
The Descendant community
and this is particularly because many
people who examine these Graves might
not recognize the aspects of
African-American burial practices from
the 17th and 18th centuries I'll give
you one example in Portsmouth
oh where the African bearing ground was
Unearthed during a sewer project maybe a
couple hundred people's Buried buried
there the bottlework to close off the
street create it reminded and so forth
um but the backhoe was digging up
um oyster shells that have been placed
in certain ways upon the grave and
that's an African custom but otherwise
they might have looked somebody just
like somebody had been dug up they also
were remains of salt
on the chests of the individuals which
was placed to keep the spirit a West
African practice and also the use of
sometimes of pins and other metal so
these are the kinds of things that might
be be recognized as Grave Goods broken
Crockery that's also a a pattern that is
ones one that is seen there so that's
why
um that kind of
um discussion
is important
I note here too on lines 24 and 25 that
there are federal Provisions that are
also on State Statute that if there
becomes an indication that this
gravesite or individual may actually be
Native American then the Native American
Graves protection and repatriation act
kicks in I was the nag Pros they call it
officer for the University of New
Hampshire about 20 years helping to deal
with archaeological collections that
have been taken from Native American
grave sites around the state over many
many decades and it's a very distinctive
provisions and if you do find a grave
that has evidence of that then that's
what kicks in so that's why it's
mentioned here that if that that becomes
apparent uh in this
um
and then uh the rest of the moving on to
the next page of the bill it provides
some
um procedures about this the
consultation of The Descendant community
and then starting on page two lines
three well okay let's say that over time
grave markers
Graves remains
uh
uh Cemetery Gates and other things
associated have been removed
sometimes they might have been taken
um into a historical society there's one
example in um Greenland New Hampshire of
or newfields excuse me of an
African-American gravestones taken out
of the woods and the place just kept
stored in the fireplace and display in
in historical society so these kinds of
things happen so um this provides a
provision that if you have these kinds
of items then they could be returned for
rebarrow replay replacement at the
gravesite
um and consultant with the community
um and uh
then um
who's going to help
with this process
this committee recommended to be that
New Hampshire division of historical
resources and uh they Ben Wilson when he
was here talking with your committee
last summer in the study provided you
know numerous numerous examples of how
many times they have taken on this role
to help local communities who have to
deal with issues around local cemeteries
and they are very much willing to help
with that process that's their job under
State Statute but also they can be a
goog liaison for municipalities that
want to connect with this the Senate
community in the state that has some
expertise in in this in this work
um the final
on part of the bill has to do
with
um well I said you know providing the
proper bearing grounds to make sure the
people who want to do research can get
their records fine
um and then the very end part of the
bill starting line is 31 to
36.
um it's it really is time for our
institutions historical institutions
museums just to to make to see if they
can go through the collections and find
out if they have
um African-American bones
other things and I will say that there
is a long history here where
um African-American Graves were dug up
to be used by medical school students
for dissection
um this began in the 1780s 90s in this
state and there's a lot of this history
around that Dartmouth medical school had
to get its uh corpses from somewhere
um and then there also was during the
19th century when there was a an attempt
to prove through so-called race science
the inferiority of people of African
descent and other and other such races
um that a lot of Bones were taken
so they can be put on display in
University and college collections for
professors who are attempting to
demonstrate through the bones the
inferiority of people of African descent
and in some cases to say they weren't
even human species at all
um so it happened
um and unfortunately there are uh
there's these remains are being found
around the country large collections
Smithsonian of course and they're trying
to make a good faith effort
um to to look
now why do we if they're trying to do an
areas why say let's really be serious
about it well for example nagpra has
been around on Native American Graves
since the early 1990s
and just two weeks ago Dartmouth found
oh as a matter of fact despite Decades
of searching and work on this we just
found 15 more remains
in their collection so it's good to look
one of the things this committee Dad Did
Last Summer which responded to museums
and Historical Society concerns about
what they had to do how extensive this
would be is it you recommended
um that uh on lines 32 and 33 reasonable
efforts reasonable you know we're not
expecting you to
drop everything that has all the staff
go through every single little thing in
your in your collection but reasonable
efforts check your records and and take
another look and see what you might have
and I will again say from my experience
at UNH where
after Decades of saying we don't have
any bones left
um they found out in a storage shed off
campus boxes and boxes of uh of of of
Bones so it it happens
nobody's a to blame here but it's time
give them five years to say let's let's
let's go through that
um so let me conclude by just giving a
couple of of examples here um I
mentioned Portsmouth
um and it's a great example of what can
happen when things are done right they
found the remains of those individuals
and they worked with with The Descendant
community and with the city of
Portsmouth to close off the street
create a monument and then re-berry the
remains and uh extraordinarily
respectful uh respectful way
there are many sites around the state
that the black Heritage Trail of New
Hampshire has identified and is putting
markers out including some burial
grounds up in in Warner and other parts
of the state I will just mention a more
recent one in Dover
um this is not somebody from the period
of enslavement but
um Nelly uh Mitchell Brown who was one
of the most famous singers of the 19th
century invented the phonitarian which
is a device for working on your tongue
positions and Pitch was an entrepreneur
started a coral uh a company
and her when she died the inscription
wasn't permanent gravestone
so um we worked with the local cemetery
and The Descendant Community to get an
appropriate inscription Hunter
gravestone and then notice in that
process that her brother was the first
African-American justice of the peace in
the state of New Hampshire and that her
husband had been a veteran of the 55th
regiment in the Civil War lost his foot
and then he had been elected one of the
first two African-American people into
the state house in Massachusetts so who
knew but within the Senate Community
gets involved it's appropriate and one
more I will mention too I think I talked
about last time owner Marie judge
Staines who was
the so-called you know enslaved as the
so-called body slave of Martha
Washington served the president and
Martha Washington
um escape from the president's house
when she got wind of a of a plan to
cycle her back
um to uh Mount Vernon and gift her to uh
Martha Washington's uh daughter who was
not somebody anybody would want to be
associated with if you read the history
nor her new husband and so she escaped
to Portsmouth New Hampshire and
Washington spent years trying to get her
back
um had somebody go up try to kidnap her
and so she fled to Greenland New
Hampshire
um she and her husband had a small piece
of land out there that you know they
lived with some people with a small
piece of land who had formed enslaved by
the minister of of Greenland and
basically hit out as a fugitive slave
until her death in the 1840s her grave
site now the gravestones that were there
have been broken shattered and uh one of
the most important historic sites really
in New Hampshire associated with our our
first first president and so forth so
that's that's one if we pass this we'll
be able to work with the property owner
with the town to send the community to
make sure that that graveyard is is
protected so started going along it's
been talked about a lot in the committee
Mr chairman and again I want to thank
you all so much for your help to make
this a better bill and I hope we can go
forward
foreign
of course we have a lot of new a lot of
new members and unfortunately uh
Ben Wilson is uh
has we had hoped we would show up does
he put He put together a very uh
give and take discussion uh how long did
it last a couple couple of hours it was
still going on it was very interesting
yeah a lot of a lot of in-depth
questions and if I may Mr chairman just
to follow up on that that um I thought
was so helpful about Ben Wilson was to
show how frequently this does happen and
the kind of issues that they that they
find in these in these Graves that are
particular to African-Americans and then
secondly uh the message loud and clear
was that local cemetery and Cemetery
commissions can handle this this is this
is something that's doable and I know
that was a committee concern last year
and I think we heard that yeah this is
doable they can turn to to him and make
first Rosemary okay thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Senator Waters
and thank you so much for bringing this
bill forward I wasn't on the committee
last year but I'm just uh really touched
by the attention to respect so thank you
my question is
um is there a database of descendants
um like if if a grave is found
um what is the the process of
identifying descendants is there a
database already available that can be
accessed
thanks for your question
um
it's it's kind of a complicated question
so I won't be too long about it
um the part of the question is do we
actually know the the full name for the
individual
um there were censuses taken in in New
Hampshire during the 18th century
perhaps the most relevant one in 1760
and then 1790 but I will say you know
New Hampshire didn't abolished slavery
until 1858 and I found record through
Census records of a young woman
enslaved in Hopkinton as late as 1850.
so there are Census records uh and then
you can try to puzzle out through online
searches as to as to whether or not
um you can follow somebody and find uh
find that record there are records as
well of the names of folks who were
transported as enslaved here and there's
a National Database
for that there are some occasions where
you can as I mentioned Samson Battis he
had many children one of his daughters
that I think something like 18 children
and they intermarried and moved around
the country you know and quite a few
stayed in New Hampshire where
uh and and that those family members
hadn't known where Samson Battis was
buried until my research came out about
that and published about it and then
um they emerged there and and were able
to step forward as descendant so it is
something of a haphazard process but
that that that's why the research is
being done by credit General New
Hampshire other National there's a
national group of African-American
genealogists very big National Group and
so work is being done but that's the
that's why we need a descendant
community that you know so often with
people who were enslaved you're just
you're going to hit dead ends on the
genealogy
but the descending Community has the
oh thank you Senator Watterson thank you
chairman
um thank you for bringing this bill
forward and I was just a question about
the Native American Graves uh protection
and repatriation act which is he said
Federal is there a similar Federal is
there anything Federal to go there's
nothing okay thanks for your question
there there are some efforts
um if you you know if you go online look
for African-American Graves you'll see
that there have been
um in the last number of years some very
important grave sites found around the
country and so people and are starting
to think about well maybe we need
something like nagpra nationally and I I
do know that there have been some
proposals about legislation and for me I
think that what's best if if this
evolves at the local level where this
expertise is because to me
I mean nagpra has particular necessity
because of the relationship between the
federal government with Native American
tribes right that's that's treaty
obligations and constitutionally
recognized
um this I kind of think we we handle the
best at the state level
hmm
thank you Mr chair um thank you Senator
waters for taking my question what we
were going over this bill a couple of
weeks ago one of the members asked me
why there is not a fiscal note on this
bill could you speak to that I'm sorry
representative I couldn't quite hear why
there's no fiscal note on the bill
yeah thank you um it's because actually
because of the good work you did last
year
um because we did not uh we did not make
it a requirement for the historical
division to do certain things to assign
Personnel to it and said they may
consult
and we did not make it a um a financial
obligation
for the local groups to do this it's a
consultative process
um and so that's why because of the
changes that you all made we avoided a
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I first just want to make a little
comment that I really appreciate the
line in there that Africa
African-American graves are sites of
conscience with historical importance I
think it
that's why we're doing this is for us to
remember the past and to acknowledge it
um
okay so I just went
but then a simple question
um
it says that final materials would be
included
and can you explain
why that's important I'm I'm again the
first paragraph of what line are we on
the very first paragraph So line two
yeah
um archaeological materials fencing
Gates funnel materials which seems like
could there could be a lot of just
contamination but why would you want to
um thanks for your question um
it there were uh
plantings
associated with that African-American
practice
and you know if you go by our historic
bearing grounds you take a close look
and you see the kind of plantings that
are there around around the perimeters
sometimes on the graves or around around
the graveyards and this is something
that you know it's really done in all
cultures
um and uh so there there are examples of
kind of particular kinds of plantings
now an archaeologist the bush may be
gone or whatever the plan is but the
archaeologists when they're doing their
dig they can find the root the root
Remains the root cavity and they can
figure out from that what was planted
there
so um and there may be seeds
uh that that were left so they're there
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'll try this way yeah I
know
um
so
I um I I won't be able to answer all my
questions here because I I've been
trying to reconcile this bill with
existing statue in like 227c and 289 14
and things like that but I'll just ask
one one specific piece um I um is there
seems to be a conflict to me between
um you know section c which talks about
um no gravesite Shelby Disturbed without
consultation
and RSA 227
c8b which is part of that Native
American burial that you had mentioned
which says that basically the state
archaeologist has 48 hours to make
arrangements with the
um uh with the property owner with a
landowner this is in the case where you
know maybe remains are found on
somebody's property and I'm trying to
understand how for example this
um uh this apparent to me anyway
conflict would be resolved
thank you
that's a question I guess it's a kind of
a process that if something just happens
to be disturbed
then
you know with any kind of grade
everything stops and people come in for
consultation and then if it's clear that
it's Native American it goes into that
path here
I think that because we're increasingly
identifying these that if it is if it
happens to be known that this is an
African-American Associated site
and there's some plan of excavation or
something then just
let's don't start it so I think it's
trying to cover both both the areas
there I'm not sure it's really a
conflict but I'm I'll go back look at
the statute
okay
um just to let you know the conflict
that I'm referring to is the amount of
time that once what is explicitly 48
hours and the other one is you know
until
um it says until uh consultation yeah oh
well thank you
um that's because it's Native American
okay I mean the Native American great
protection is just very very strong at
the federal and the state level as it
should be
um and I thought that that perhaps is
appropriate for Native American Graves
but maybe because we're not doing the
federal statute here that this would be
more reasonable to do it this way for
these groups
foreign
[Laughter]
um
so um
the descending Community the way I I
think that we worked on it last summer
with you all was that the assumption is
that this that the historical resources
who does have connection with
such groups would be able to help
identify in part one of the city what
circumstances may be and what part of
stated it is in
um
for example
um the blackheader trail New Hampshire
has done a number of these projects and
they would be you know they're
absolutely well known
um by the division and then there are in
some other parts of the of the state
there are other organizations that would
be willing to work on this whether it's
NAACP chapter
um the black Heritage Trail of New
Hampshire is willing to go Statewide
but it might be there's a lot more local
group it could be a church group it
could be a you know it could be a church
that has um
the folks who who because they're in a
town want to want to do this but I think
that rather you know the committee was
uneasy last year with naming any one
group so that's why
um that would be in the Judgment call
of the division as to whom to consult
with that
so it would be similar to just an
organization that exists and
and they've and and the grave is found
that there wouldn't be an organization
waiting there for in that town that
that's our you know yeah that's or they
or there actually could be but yeah but
there isn't that isn't what you would
would expect with the discovery some
group would step forward yes and um
expectation and I'll suggest Mr chairman
another another option too that was done
in Portsmouth
uh Anna Dover as well that the
municipality decides to establish a
group so what Portsmouth did is it
established a um negro bearing ground
committee that included uh represents of
the city but also um rep you know
various Representatives the
African-American Community drawn from
the the community
um and Dover has set up
um as a designated a liaison
um from the city council uh to work with
the Quaker Meeting House and uh members
of the black Heritage Trail New
Hampshire and a group called project
dream which is an African-American group
in the high school so that I mean I
think it's important about the
municipality have that flexibility
um if they want to you know get some
help from the division contacting an
existing group like black Heritage Trail
fine if they'd rather do it locally as I
just described that would work too
flexibility
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you Mr chairman I have
to go to caucus but if anybody needs me
they know how to get a hold of me okay
uh
Barbara
Ward okay
yeah
and representing black Heritage Trail of
is that on already yes it is
um I just I my name is Barbara Ward and
I live in Portsmouth New Hampshire and
I'm senior grant writer and special
projects coordinator for the black
Heritage Trail of New Hampshire and I
sit on our marker committee and work
with individuals who are doing research
I'm a historian myself and so I work
with many of our volunteers who do
historic research
I'm here on behalf of myself as an
interested historian and on behalf of
the black Heritage Trail of New
Hampshire to speak in favor of the bill
we've been active at the trail in
working with communities across the
state who've discovered African-American
gravesites in their communities and in
the last six months our our office
manager says that the number of
inquiries has really increased with
people looking for help on what to do
respectful
ways to respectively respectfully
remember individuals who have unmarked
sites who they've located and are aware
of and we also work with an individual
who's done a great deal as a volunteer
to help people identify grave sites
Underground
through ground penetrating radar so he's
been a great his name is David Palance
he's been a great resource too for
people in helping to identify where
grave sites unmarked grave sites are are
located
um
because many of the grave sites are
unmarked and um
like the grave sites in Portsmouth that
were known to be in that General
vicinity but were not in any way marked
and had been covered Over By A Street in
fact and by houses
um
it's really important to have this bill
I think as a next step in this process
because it is possible that remains can
be uncovered people don't know are there
um and I'm pleased that Senator Waters
mentioned the uh
the grave site of owner Marie judge
stains and um also the members of the
Jacks family because these are the kinds
of grave sites that we know are
endangered and we hope to be able to
protect I want to say that we at the
black Heritage Trail support the bills
provision designating the New Hampshire
division of historical resources as the
entity that will select representatives
of The Descendant Community we know that
there are as as Senator Waters mentioned
a lot of groups working throughout the
state a lot of very interested people
coming forward and and looking for
assistance but also people who've done a
great deal of their own research and
with this as research and queries are
posted on the internet and are available
through all the many
available
genealogical records online it's amazing
how many people are coming forward to
identify themselves and to work with the
communities here in
here in New Hampshire so I think there
is certainly the possibility that local
groups will be able to to provide some
of this information as well
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
um so regarding the um you know the
location of these sites that are
sometimes unmarked and sometimes not
there's no nothing even visible above
ground I'm wondering how you can
this is too related thoughts in this
question I'm wondering how you can
determine that they are African-American
remains and I'm wondering um if the
provisions of RSA 289 14 that say that
we um that a um that a abandoned or
burial ground can be preserved by
petitioning uh the local community
selectman for example the town to allow
an organization to maintain that grave
site if that would suffice
um for your ability for these
organizations ability to
um to to protect these these graveyard
sites well I think that I think that
Senator Waters made the made the remark
that in some cases you're talking about
special ways in which I'm sorry I can't
see you through the
um that there are special ways in which
the uh the individuals were buried
and unless you are aware of respecting
those
um you know which what's found such as
was found with the in the case of the
Portsmouth African bearing ground that
that sort of that sort of thing could be
overlooked I mean I know with the owner
Jacks uh I mean the Ona judge and Jack's
site in Greenland there are adjacent
walls and other other
parts of that burial site that could be
very important when you're thinking in
terms of African Traditions as well as
as well as
perhaps local Traditions as far as
knowing that the sites are there one of
the things that very often happens is
that there are sections of graveyards
that were designated as being for
poppers
and so they're unmarked grave sites and
the again people are are finding it's
really through a lot of documentary
research and one of the amazing things
to me is although we say that we don't
know this information now or we're
discovering it you very often find that
it was well known in the 19th century
um and that it was written about and
individuals were identified then as to
where they were where they were buried
um and so and you can look in Probate
records of people who enslave these
people to determine that in fact they
were they were buried we know we don't
always know where but I know one in
particular where the funeral expenses
for an enslaved man appear in the estate
records of the individual it doesn't say
where he was buried but it does say that
the estate paid for the expense of
burying him
nonetheless there's no marked grave for
him so it's uh I think it's a case where
there's really very special kind of
research that has to go into this
in order to find these people in order
to respect the special Traditions that
Mark the way that they were interred
originally
thank you I know she know better right
I am Linda Gap right and I'm out of
Nashua Hills 11 and also Ward 9. however
I'm here today as representing greater
Nashville NAACP which we fully support
this bill
I'm also representing Manchester and ACP
as well as Seacoast NAACP
who's under the leadership of Jim McCann
and Reverend Bob Thompson and I am the
I find this really uh
a very serious issue because
when the graves were found in Portsmouth
my sister church is there and my church
out of Nashua would go to New Hope in
um Portsmouth and under Dr Hilson who
was now deceased
um and it was very moving a very moving
situation to even discover that things
of that nature happen and the fact that
it happened
and those that covered the grave knew it
was a grave site and that's what I find
to be strongly disappointing in New
Hampshire
I wanted to read a testimony that the
young lady she's the vice president of
the NAACP youth Council and she did
provide testimony to the Senators when
they had their hearing for the bill and
it's short and simple and she says her
name is Reka mahadovan
and she says
she recounted a story of how an unmarked
burial site of children who were
enslaved was found in her hometown in
Madbury New Hampshire now I hadn't heard
of that so I was really surprised of
that testimony
Miss Manhattan noted how other burial
sites are properly marked and respected
unlike those of former enslaved in her
own hometown
Miss madivan mentioned how New Hampshire
is not just a white State and that it
has a rich African-American culture
dating back to the start of the nation
and I had to concur with her on that
and so for me this bill ensures that
there are procedures for when dealing
with the burial site containing the
remains of enslaved folks would be dealt
with respectfully and I think that's the
the main key to this is that it would be
dealt with respectfully with some type
of committee or group of people that um
that would work it out so that even when
the bodies are returned to whatever
grade it's done in a respectful way
so I thank you for your time
and your energy on this subject
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
I have no additional cards anyone else
anybody from the audience
see
that
thank you very much I'll close the
hearing and uh
Senate bill 11.
uh it's unfortunate that uh
what it's happening again is
versus the person who was supposed to be
here from uh historical did not show up
uh we did have a
a special we did have a a special
meeting
for that
last year but I think it'd be good for
him to be back here again to this to
discuss
the old procedures he's an expert on
what happens when
at any time they find a uh a grave site
or a body uh in you know in the in uh in
the in the
in with the woods or something like that
and even if it's not a known grave site
and what what to do and what in the
procedures that that they do go through
and they are some significant procedures
so
yep it's Ben Wilson
Mr chairman would it be
um appropriate to ask Mr Wilson to be
here when we accept this bills if there
are questions during our discussion I
plan to have him here for a work session
oh okay thank you
that I think a work session we would not
be under any pressure
to uh and we to get uh the time or
anything like that and we we could we
could we could discuss individual
portions this bill has many different
portions of uh there's different instant
different uh segments to it and we
probably won't discuss it representative
wolf
thank you Mr chairman
um like a previous bill
um
is there objection to this bill do we
have a consensus and could we uh and
second right now no
okay
saying that and close the hearing
pardon I think you did I did did I close